so I wake up this morning
and the first thing I do when I wake up
is I grab my phone off the show off the
nightstand and I'm just like I'm like
swiping through and then I see Kanye
West is buying parlor and I was like huh
well today's gonna be really weird and
yes this was just the first story so not
only is Kanye West buying parlor after
being censored more more interviews have
come out where he's talking about Jewish
people and okay we'll have to talk about
that but then I saw that I think it's
let me just let me just make sure it's
Boston University I think yeah Boston
lab I don't know if it's University they
took the spike protein from almicron
which is infectious and combined it with
the alpha stream which is deadly
creating a coveted strain that is an 80
mortality rate wow what great news today
I suppose there was some good news the
polls are all starting to shift rather
dramatically inflation has gotten so bad
that the GOP is now starting to take the
lead in tons of Nationwide polls which I
guess is good news if you're tired of
Biden and the Democrats fail to get
anything done they like to talk about
how Republicans are blocking them but uh
sorry man the Republicans don't have any
power right now I mean they've got the
minority in in Congress they're not in
the executive branch so this is all
Democrats doing not that I think the
Republicans are going to solve anything
but hey sure whatever maybe we'll get
some good people in to do something so
we're going to talk about all of this
and obviously there's a lot more
Ulta is being boycotted because they
released a podcast featuring two adult
males talking about quote the beauty of
girlhood which has resulted in I think
what the cut refers to as turfs
boycotting Ulta so that should be fun to
talk about before we get into all that
my friends head over to timcast.com and
become a member support our work we got
an amazing
on the ground reporting clip we send out
illad Elijo our field reporter he's
asking fetterman supporters about when
John fetterman chased an innocent black
man with a gun he he got a gun and
chased this guy some dude gets him in
his face screaming at him they don't
care about the politics they claim to
care about and I think uh you know it's
a really great clip that really shows a
lot of what these people actually
believe so elad is he's a straight
shooter man he doesn't go he doesn't do
gotcha questions This Is How They
genuinely responded him asking a real
question about the campaign it's because
of your support as members we can
produce these clips and get reporters on
the ground and writing these stories and
as a member you'll get access to the
members only uncensored show tonight at
11 PM which I imagine you're really
going to want to watch because joining
us today we have two awesome guests
first we have Chadwick Moore Hey great
to be here thanks for having me
absolutely who are you uh I'm a
journalist I'm a contributing editor at
The Spectator I am also Editor in Chief
of outspoken which is a LGBT Centric
Free Speech opinion and news site and uh
I've got a book out now called so you've
been sent to diversity training
it's a really fun romp into the
nefarious and rampant business of Dei
training in the workplace so I get to
talk to I talked to police officers guys
in the military uh guys on oil rigs
secretaries CEOs about their experiences
with Dei and uh it was really fun it's a
really funny book so I like to check it
out I like to say diversity inclusivity
and Equity yes yeah die yeah and uh
Biden just add an a to it so it's now
it's d-e-i-a for accessibility so it's
becoming like lgbtq you're just gonna
keep adding lessons accessibility he has
a new executive order about that yeah
exactly oh maybe that's because about
that's fetterman maybe like that might
be a big deal when him too fetterman's
using this this machine to translate
sound to detect so right and understand
what people are saying because he can't
his brain isn't processing it anymore
right yeah there you go there yep yep
they're already adding it all right and
well thanks for joining us we also have
the ever wonderful Blair white hey okay
thanks for having me again so I'm a
YouTuber social and political political
commentator fourth time on the show now
last time Alex Jones was blowing my
eardrum out
I'm gonna talk tonight and I'm excited
and of course you can get your your
t-shirts from Luke damn right uh it's
been uh it's been a real sausage fest
here lately ever since uh Lydia left I
come here more like him cast right
exactly I come here with one simple
message don't nuke me bro
was inspired by Andrew Mayer my friend
the don't tase me bro who confronted
John Kerry if you like the shirt you
could get it on
thebestpoliticalshorts.com but be
careful Insider might see it as a very
violent message
right on we also got surge pressing all
the buttons yeah what's up Splurge I am
here you heard it first from Luke and uh
I am the producer for sausage cast IRL
oh
yeah there's no women here anymore but
today we're good right yeah all right
inclusivity yes all right let's jump
into this first story we have this from
tipguess.com Kanye West to buy social
media platform parlor after being
censored on Twitter and Instagram hey
good for him I was just I this came out
of nowhere was there any any Whisper of
Kanye West wanting to buy any social
media platforms let alone
what was it knee-jerk because of the
Banning or had this been in the works
for a while I I guess man I want to make
a lot of people don't know this because
I don't know if anybody wrote about it
but we're gonna talk about it sorry
parlor look I got no beef but when
parlor was issuing the release about
this purchase confirming it they they
accidentally copied every I'm assuming
what's every PR email and uh
there's just hundreds of people so I get
an email
with hundreds of other emails attached
to it and I get these PR emails all the
time normally what happens is you blind
carbon copy someone so you put all your
PR contacts in BCC so no one can see
anybody else but they accidentally just
carbon copied every one of their
contacts I'm assuming everyone puts
hundreds and then all of a sudden I
start getting responses people are
emailing me and I'm like wait what's
happening why is like who's this guy and
then all of a sudden I see a bunch of
people I know that are on this email
thread and I'm like yo parlor just sent
out the email addresses of all these
VIPs and high profile people to everyone
else so now we've got like you know
Charlie Kirk you said diamond and silk
yeah Fairbanks on it I'm on it Joey
salads oh yeah yeah I got the entire I
think it's probably every verified
account who has a parlor a through J wow
I was included on
yeah
users yeah that's maybe that's what it
is because it's not press reps it's
famous people uh some members of the
Trump family I saw on there wow Trump
adjacent people so I've got lot of email
addresses now well I guess all of these
all of these high profile people are
media personalities so yeah yeah
overlaps politicos and media
personalities look like so that happened
and uh they sent me an email apologizing
and so it's like you know these things
happen but this happened and I kind of I
was kind of thinking like this might be
like a big story because there might be
some people who don't want anyone to
know that they've been in communication
with parlor or something like that so
one one email from a from a from someone
said like they seem to pass they said
parlor really values our privacy I guess
and it was pretty little but anyway
anyway back to Kanye does this story
matter
what
of artists especially rappers changing
their names and we're all supposed to go
along with it like now right I'm not
going to say yay I feel stupid saying
yay I want to say Kanye like how many
names did Peta do you have like ten yeah
it was like every week that's why I just
had to get that out of the out of the
out of the gate but I also had a fight
with P Diddy well now they've had a big
fight yeah oh yeah the text well that's
where a lot of those comments came out
of wasn't it yeah yeah yeah but you know
what I love when Diddy changed his name
South Park really went for it do you
remember that episode where it's like
did he do it did he did do it
he didn't do it but then he changed it
back to P Diddy right now let's just
full circle back when I was a kid he was
Puff Daddy yeah yeah and then he was
Sean puppy Combs and then it was how
many other names since then it was a few
it was a few yeah it was a lot of meme
yeah I don't I don't know what that's
about but you know he can call himself
whatever I want the question is you know
look parlor was I I think parlor may
have been about to displace Twitter it
was growing so rapidly it was the top of
the charts everybody was getting on it
and they really had this momentum and
then big Tech colluded all at once with
a false pretext January 6 to just ban
them out right yeah yeah so they have
that poddler did have you know a big
impact but I don't know if it's there
anymore I guess Kanye is just making
sure he can't be banned from any kind of
social media he'll still be able to post
stuff well yeah he was he was banned
from of course Twitter and Instagram
because of his uh you know salacious
comments that of course he was making he
he's also being described by some people
as an artistic genius and other people
is just a crazy lunatic either way I
think there's going to be some exciting
changes coming to parlor it's going to
be interesting to see what he does with
the platform he he definitely is an
outside of the box thinker to say the
least he also was just caught wearing a
Satoshi Nakamoto hat he was just
debanked by of course JP Morgan and
Chase the bank of Jeffrey Epstein who of
course
he got debanked and then wore a Satoshi
Nakamoto right yes yes so obviously so
for those are not familiar that's a
Bitcoin that's the Bitcoin founder
exactly so clearly he's making a
statement about the banking industry so
so yet again you know some people are
saying he's just an artist just trying
to sell his records some people are
saying he's really trying to change
change things in societies it all
depends on what you really kind of think
of him as an individual but but you know
it's not boring
new life as well it could be something
entirely different afterwards and it
could come back well he I think that's
it right he did a lot of interesting
things in the sneaker industry you know
criticized him for his words but but he
at least changed things up and made him
a little bit more Innovative a little
bit more different a little bit more
artistic a little bit more out of the
box because we just continue to see the
same old kind of routines and I might
not agree with his statements but but I
still think crazy people should have a
voice artistic savants should have a
voice no matter if you agree with it or
disagree with it I think that voice is
important to understand where someone
truly is and censoring it isn't going to
help anybody I don't think he's crazy I
don't think he's crazy like yeah he he
may be eccentric but he's clearly
followed very very specific logical
paths to become a billionaire and his
his net worth Rivals that of trump it's
like Trump's worth more but Kanye is you
know relatively close in terms of being
a billionaire there is however his
statements he made about Jewish people
controlling you know uh Diddy or Puff
Daddy I don't know what's the guy's name
is you know you know yeah
he made comments about that he made more
comments on another podcast apparently
he did an interview and they didn't air
it and then he did another interview
he's like I don't even know if you guys
are gonna are gonna air this because he
won't air my comments but he's made
comments about Jewish people that I
think are either he's he's speaking very
very poorly or he's just completely
wrong and has really bad information and
I think people people can be susceptible
to conspiracy theories when they read
things that are incorrect it doesn't
mean I don't think he's insane you know
I think he just he thinks things that
aren't correct or he's expressing
himself in a very poor way let me let me
put it this way or or he's expressing
himself in a way that galvanizes media
attention so he could sell his product
better to you so maybe potentially was a
big rift or something maybe maybe it's
just a way of just getting attention he
said something like repeal the 13th
Amendment right I can't something like
that wasn't there a segment that was
edited out of Fox News
yeah yeah with what the Tucker interview
yeah yeah she's had some [ __ ] about
Jewish people I don't yeah he's I think
he was like saying Black Hebrew
Israelite stuff and then there's the
Tweet the Defcon Jewish people that was
crazy yeah but then he's also made the
comments about uh Derek Chauvin and
George Floyd here's the point they're
gonna sue him he he said something about
uh repealing the 13th Amendment and
everyone claimed that he was pro-slavery
he clarified what he meant was the 13th
amendment allows slavery it specifically
says if you're incarcerated it says you
can't be a slave unless you're
incarcerated or something like that like
and what he was saying is you shouldn't
be able to be enslaved for any reason
he's actually correct we should ban
slavery in all capacities but because
he's not he didn't speak very well
people misconstrue what he was saying
now I got to ask I don't know what he
could have meant by those Jewish
comments I think he's read a whole bunch
of crackpot conspiracy stuff and he's
believing some stupid stuff that's about
it yeah and there is something to be
said about how he has his bank account
closed and you're right Jeffrey
rapstein's wasn't and they even had like
a press release about why they weren't
going to close Jeffrey Epstein's like
back before even when there was red
flags and warnings and he was a
convicted person who hurt children right
but you know someone's words are worse
apparently than sex trafficking but no
no I I think there was also a
clarification on that specific story and
that he was actually debanked before
making those statements oh so he got
debunked then he came out and made those
statements was it for the White lives
matter shirt then uh what did he do yeah
I don't know again like who knows here's
something else Candace Owen's husband is
the CEO of parlor that makes sense yeah
so
that could be why it happened so quickly
Kanye knows Candace he meets George
farmer I think is his name and then
Kanye's like you need money for this
I'll buy it and he probably okay and
then he like it's a private company so
they just went sure let's let's roll I
think this might actually be really big
Kanye buying parlor might actually be
the bigger threat to Twitter yeah I was
asking if the story mattered but here's
here's what I want to I want to add to
this it's possible Kanye is famous okay
we get it he's got a lot of fans who
follow him because his story isn't just
about his music it's about a success so
there are a lot of young men that see
Kanye and they want to be like him they
want to be a billionaire now he's buying
parlor they're gonna go join it because
they want to hang out with Kanye the
media can say whatever they want about
him they can't do anything about it if I
was Kanye I'd be hiring a bunch of
security guards because he's got a lot
of people that are real pissed off and
that's it's dangerous out there man and
with Kanye owning parlor then it maybe
won't be necessarily like a right wing
social media you know what I mean it
might be actually just apolitical people
his fans that have no interest or aren't
even right-wing you know so it could be
a big deal if black Twitter moves over
to parlor then exactly yeah if black
putter leaves and Twitter's over yeah
100 and that would make it not that I
mean we see these alternative social
media sites yes we're glad they exist
but you know it's all right Wingers and
that's that's always my issue it's like
why I'm not on gab and all these things
it's like I don't want to just talk to
people who yeah I would take the hate
over just blinding you can't control
yeah you can't fight you can't troll
that's true yeah the troll is the most
important part I mean that's why I love
the internet yeah that's why I love
Twitter you know I'm like I get the
troll people people get the troll me
this is awesome
mostly like my Twitter is I'm I'm like
my followers are mostly in the joke but
sometimes they're not and it's weird
that they don't get it yeah like I've
tweeted a bunch of a bunch of crazy
stuff I tweeted like have you considered
spaying and neutering your children to
prevent overpopulation and there are
people following me being like yo bad
take Tim I can't believe you would say
this and I'm just like welcome to
Twitter dude I do not take this platform
seriously it is full of nonsense right
well that's autism and I'm autistic so I
can say that is it is that what I don't
know I think I'm just taking it so
bluntly and seriously oh I see I see
like not not understanding the social
cues yeah that's that's really crazy to
me that I don't understand how people I
I kind of feel like people are
pretending to not get that my jokes make
no sense because they want to have
something to be angry about that's true
too like the anime thing with Matt Walsh
he's like yeah so for those who didn't
see Matt Walsh Media Matters went after
him because he said what do I think
about anime I think it's satanic I don't
have an argument for it but you know
something demonic about it and then
everybody who goes nuts and it's just
like
these are not serious people and you
don't insult anime fans because I was on
the pop culture show earlier and I said
something like you know what constitutes
being
anime does it have to be Japanese or not
people got so upset they're like no it's
also from here and here and here I was
like oh my God yeah let me not even
bother these people it's like a whole
universe you don't know exists until you
kick a hornet's nest yeah and they all
come after you yeah yeah I I my favorite
was when Matt Walsh said that the little
mermaid should have translucent skin and
look like a floating skeleton and they
said it was racist or something yeah
they're like he's racist because there's
a black mermaid it's like
I do and then what did he tweet he's
like they're mad because I'm defending
translucent he called himself a trans
rights activist for translucent
translucent yeah
you know it's like
it's less like in a lot of ways we're on
the verge of the Apocalypse for one
reason or another but at least there's
funny things happening as we ride the
the gravity bomb down to you know the
apocalypse the downfall is funny yeah
and it kind of keeps getting hey what
else are you gonna do yeah be angry it's
just the collapse of you know
civilization
yeah yeah I choose to laugh yes always
you guys exactly do you want uh this one
all right let's let's laugh and cry I
feel like with a story like this you
could either laugh or cry oh God this is
from The Daily Mail this is playing with
fire it could spark a lab generated
pandemic how about that expert slam
Boston lab where scientists have created
a new deadly covet string with an 80
kill rate why why are they making this
so here's what they did actually simple
so the Omicron strain mutated over a
long period of time kovid goes out covid
kills a lot of people the alpha strain
was very deadly over time it was getting
more infectious but weaker that's how
viruses are to go the Omicron strain was
very infectious but not as deadly that
makes sense if something's too deadly
people die before they can spread the
disease so these researchers took the
spike protein from Omicron and put it on
the alpha strain which is more deadly
creating an extremely infectious and
deadly virus which killed eight and ten
of the rodents infected why wow why did
they make this oh a Christmas present
yeah why why was you know Peter dazek of
echo Hut's Alliance doing similar
projects back before of course the
larger coveted pandemic that happened
when he was exactly looking at bats and
coronaviruses in the Wuhan level 3
Institute of virology that of course had
poor security protocols according to
many even State Department protocols and
documents that came out there why did
they do this and the question is they're
doing this on even bigger levels than we
could even imagine and the argument here
the basic argument that they're making
is we need to do this in order so we
find a solution for it in the future
number one a lot of scientists argue
that the probability of something like
this happening naturally is virtually
almost impossible but but two why are
you trying to make this current strain
that much worse when you couldn't even
figure out the original strain there is
no solution there is no medical solution
towards the original strain so why are
you studying why you are you wasting so
much time looking at some hypothetical
when you can't even figure out the
original problem so so that's something
that needs to be understood here as well
as the fact that again
Peter dazek is continuing to do the same
experiments in other countries we know
about this because it's it's Boston
University but what about the studies in
Laos what about the studies in Myanmar
what about the studies going on right
now in Vietnam that we don't know
anything about that Echo Health Alliance
by the way was was was subuned was told
by the US government hey you got to send
us your notes about what you guys were
doing with the coronavirus in Wuhan the
ecohealth alliance even though they were
financed by the US government by Dr
fauji said no we're just not going to
give you any of the notes they're not
being transparent and they're being
rewarded with more grants that were just
issued a couple weeks ago continuing to
make viruses as lethal as they can why
are they doing this a lot of people
speculate bio weapons and this could be
one reason why Bill Gates came out a few
months ago and said the second pandemic
is going to be a lot deadlier he said
that very promisingly and who in the
world happily probably what's that
saying we spend so much time wondering
if we could do it we never asked
ourselves if we should do it something
like that yeah I I'm like reading this
story where they're talking about
taking this protein and making you know
the so so the Omicron strain infected
mice the mice did not die they then
created like the Omicron s strain or
whatever they're calling it and it
killed eight out of ten and they were
like oh look we did it we made something
that can kill mice it's like you know I
look at that and I'm like yeah you could
have injected them with bleach that
would have killed him too right like
obviously this like you make a deadly
virus it will kill them I just I don't
trust them we had a conversation with
Drew Miller who has a PHD in you know
nuclear wartime battle field stuff or
whatever and he was saying
he was talking about how we have no bio
labs in the united like the United
States does not operate bioweapons labs
and I'm like it's just semantics if U.S
Laboratories are making extremely deadly
viruses that they're extremely
infectious and extremely lethal and you
argue they're not weapons because we
don't use them for that and I'm like so
so okay so so the question is if I have
a factory that make explosives
but we we use it for mining operations
right we're not making weapons then
someone comes in buys buys the company
and then sells them for war did we make
weapons or not
right so Like a Knife Company we we make
you know uh fancy knives for culinary
purposes and then someone buys them and
goes and fights with them did the
company manufacture weapons the answer
is yes they manufacture weapons was it
their intent no but it doesn't matter so
we're seeing this and I'm like hey that
is a bio weapon Now call it whatever you
want say what you want whatever you want
about it if you make a nuclear bomb and
say we just want to see if it would
explode I'll bet yeah okay well you're
making nuclear weapons yeah what's
there's no it's you know what man and I
can make the argument knives culinary
knives have a purpose you you can cut
your steak you know how what are you
gonna do you got you want to eat dinner
you gotta this virus has no purpose it's
literal the only purpose is killing
people so yeah anyway well these
researchers who I would assume know the
chronovirus better than anyone on earth
have looked at it more than anyone
obviously have they said anything in the
report about yes this was definitely
man-made in the lab or they've forbidden
from saying that do they know a lot
about this virus since again the
official story is we don't even know
exactly where it came from yeah we don't
have an origin we don't have a patient
zero we don't have any of that well
someone knows someone of course knows
but there's been a large cover-up effort
Echo Health Alliance doesn't want to
share their notes about what they were
even doing what U.S grant money from Dr
pouchy in 2020 right I thought it was uh
someone ate bat soup a block away from
the Wuhan
[ __ ] the Pangolin first and that's how
it came yeah there's also a peglin
involved here I think that was an
episode of South Park as well yeah uh
but again no official stories too yeah
and ever since ever since covert there
has been there have been 40 new
biological Labs that have been started
up doing extremely dangerous testing mix
mixing and viruses and again there's no
perfect security at these places like we
have to understand it takes one small
mistake it takes one whole one puncture
one is mistake one intern
and that virus spreads everywhere so
where is the all these worthless
International organizations we have
where is the International effort and
treaty against
perforations
we have it all with nuclear weapons
where is this going on well bio weapons
are apparently banned under treaties and
that's what we were talking about last
week and so it's like we're not making
weapons we're just making extremely
deadly viruses that serve no purpose
other than killing yeah right yeah so so
yeah we look at those treaties again and
and exactly say what kind of research is
permitted what isn't well what if this
is a question that was brought up what
if all these other countries are doing
it and the US isn't
yeah exactly so you know with mutually
assured destruction I suppose the
argument is you know if we didn't have
nuclear weapons we'd be at the behest or
or you know of anyone else then they can
call if anyone else who has nukes who
can threaten us so everybody gets them
and then you can't bully someone
you could say something similar for uh
any kind of Bio weapon it's like hey we
all have them so you better not release
them if the US wasn't doing it would
that be a risk I think the problem with
bioweapons is they're completely
undetectable with a nuclear weapon we
can see who did it yeah okay that came
from Russia and it's a Russian missile
somebody gets sick we have no idea what
it is or where it came from and then
it's going to spread everywhere and
affect everybody and yeah and this is
what's public imagine what's not public
imagine what secret imagine what else
they're doing that we don't know about
that's not in the United States that's
in Myanmar or in Ukraine or wherever it
may be that these people are taking
their money investing it and doing
research in extremely poor countries
where there's no transparency there's no
accountability and they prey on poorer
countries because they're able to get
away with more disastrous nasty stuff
that they wouldn't be able to get away
with here in the United States 2020
could have been the warm-up honestly
yeah I mean that's what Bill Gates says
Bill Gates says this is this is only one
of many pandemics to come you know he's
excited yeah he said he said the second
second pandemic is going to be a lot
deadlier than this one is and I'll and
I'll verify too I mean this is in mice
so how that directly translates may be
very very different they like it may be
much much higher in my centers in humans
but they're basically making the point
that
the Omicron they tested didn't kill any
of the mice they made it more deadly it
killed 80 of them eight out of 10. so
we'll see I got a prediction
I think
we talked about this again we we
broached the subject on how a bio weapon
would be released and I said I think
that any nation that releases a
bioweapon will release a mild strain of
it on their own country first
here's what happens they create two
viruses hypothetically any country
the deadly variant and the mild variant
but they're very very similar they share
a lot of the same attributes they
release on their own population the flu
everybody gets it
point one percent mortality or point
zero one or whatever it is for the flu
then they release the massive maximum 60
deadly strain
on somewhere else in the world and when
that strain comes back to their country
their people already have immunity to
that to that to a variant of it so
they're much much less susceptible we
saw this with a Spanish Flu many people
wondered why it was that in China they
didn't actually get hit as hard as the
rest of the world when it came to
Spanish food it was like 1918 I think
and one of the arguments is that a
similar version was actually in China
they all got sick but not that bad got
immunity to it when it spread around in
the trenches and with the infections and
the grime it got substantially worse and
then when it came back to China they
were already mostly immune to it so now
that we're hearing they've they're
making what whether or not it's this
this coveted virus or whatever here's my
prediction my prediction is we see a
deadly strain of covid but it will
mostly just impact people countries that
haven't faced the severity of this which
I wonder which countries that is
countries with very low covet infection
and mortality rates I wonder what those
countries are do you know Luke usually
the places that weren't a part of the
the program that injected uh unknown
rushed experimental uh needles
if you look at the countries that have
the most debts are the places the ones
that had the biggest vaccination program
let's just be real right and those and
that's why they were putting the
vaccination programs there because they
had more death there are specific
countries around the world mostly in the
third world that had very low coveted
death and infection rates so they didn't
bring vaccines there but but if these
people don't have the immunity either
you know for vaccine or whatever reason
then you're going to see a deadlier
strain severely impact third world
countries in this in this case well
scientists see it just you know there's
a lot of scientific debate that's
actually being censored around the
specific topic especially when it comes
to you know countries like Haiti
comparatively to Israel Singapore what
happened there to other places but uh at
the end of the day natural immunity is
something that again also a topic that
has been sent answered a lot but natural
immunity has been key to a lot of
people's personal health and getting
through a lot of this nonsense and
bullcrap do you guys think Americans
would be willing to lock down again
because I questioned that in my head
like if they just did it all over again
I don't know no way where I live in New
York they would they're they're dying
well that's the thing blue States when
they're freaking out they were not
locked down right but people are moving
to Florida and Texas yeah and so the
blue States probably would because you
have a higher density now of the people
who want to live under the boot right
right and then
South Dakota Florida Texas a bunch of
red States they wouldn't do it West
Virginia probably wouldn't do it yeah
yeah I don't know did New Hampshire Do
It
um not not it depends where because the
big cities especially with a lot of
people condensed they had their own
little versions of it but the government
is very limited in New Hampshire so it
was up to a lot of personal individuals
personal businesses to decide for
themselves but as far as comparing it to
New York it was day and night to what
was going on there
um you know it depends what happens you
know there's also a scientific thoughts
and ideas that if a virus is more deadly
it's less contagious but they're talking
about how this bio uh bio lab made
Weapon It's sorry excuse me this new
strain of of coven made by Boston
University they're saying it was a
university I just want to be I think
Austin University are you sure uh yeah
uh you could double check just to make
sure we're right on this that ball
you're right you're right you're right
yeah but Boston University is also
reporting that this is five times more
contagious than the original covet virus
so it's more contagious and more deadly
that's that's something you know pretty
serious there because naturally viruses
uh just want to spread they want to live
they want to go from host to host to
host and not kill the host because when
you kill the host you stop the spread of
the virus so this one with the data that
they're reporting is very troubling
because High death count and high
transmability you know transmission
ability yeah so it's
let's get apocalyptic this is the
greatest headline that's ever been
written ever from Business Insider
Putin's nuclear threats are pushing
people like Trump and Elon Musk who
press for a Ukraine peace deal a nuclear
expert warns that's dangerous
wow
1984. here we are so good that is I it's
it's the best you know the reason why
it's the greatest is because you could
have just said war is peace you know or
whatever yeah but they they really went
for it's very long yeah and it really
Nails the piece is dangerous right I
love that nuclear winter is actually
spring
well well hold on it is dangerous
because a small nuclear war could stop
climate change am I killing tons of
people I guess yeah you guys saw that
article from Huntington post right no
it's like from 10 years ago it says
could a small nuclear war reverse
climate change
yeah argument like lowering the carbon
footprint of the population like yes the
carbon footprint is in the human beings
that are carbon yeah there you go okay
well let's let's see what they actually
have to say about this story
they say an understandable desire to
avoid a nuclear war could actually make
the world more dangerous if it means
rushing to implement a peace in Ukraine
that serves Russian interests an expert
told inside oh an expert
such a move which some influential
figures have called for risks setting a
precedent that Atomic blackmail is the
way to win Wars and take territory
troops can't otherwise hold a model that
could be Complicated by even the weakest
nuclear-armed States and may only
succeed at delaying Another War
an expert on Russia's nuclear Doctrine
and capabilities of the UN Institute for
disarmament research said in a phone
interview from Geneva such a deal on
terms deemed favorable by Moscow in the
wake of a battlefield of Battlefield
losses and an explicit response to the
kremlin's nuclear brinksmanship could
well make the world much less peaceful
the West supports Ukraine with weapons
and financial and moral and political
support giving that up and saying that
well you know we're too afraid of
nuclear threats and we just want to make
a deal that would certainly set a
precedent that would not be very
positive if you yielded this nuclear
threat once then what would prevent
Russia and the future or others to do
the same thing again how about nuclear
weapons in countries like the United
States and positioned in NATO and what
we're talking about right now is Ukraine
which is not a NATO member State not a
EU member State not in a position where
we should be sending weapons U.S
Personnel NATO citizens Special
Operations intelligence and engaging in
war with Russia hey how about that you
want to come and claim that I got the
point they're trying to make but it's
bunk Russia is having a border dispute
they invaded Ukraine it's a border
dispute that has not involved the United
States we've made it our business for
some reason that's the problem plus more
importantly it's historically inaccurate
look what happened during the Cold War
it was only because of de-escalation it
was only because of Peace deals we
didn't blow each other up and it didn't
lead to of course a misbalance of of
power and again this is just a lunatic
sociopla sociopathic bloodthirsty neocon
Warhawk that's spewing utter nonsense
literally trying to tell you that war is
peace what is about our current
trajectory playing nuclear war chicken
that is going to be leading to any kind
of resolution or peace as we're only
seeing escalations where's the
de-escalations where's the peace talks
where's the negotiations none of that
and it makes me nervous because it
reminds me of right before covid and
people were just kind of talking about
viruses and all of a sudden the world
changed in ways you didn't expect was
like it feels like that like right
before something big I got a pitch for
the U.N
for Joe Biden and for NATO all right you
want to get people in on this war here's
how you play it you guys ever play
Fallout 3
no Luke yeah yeah
follow three a while ago you know hey
fun game huh it was yeah you never
played it no no what what's the what's
the nuclear apocalypse happens and you
come out of a vault afterwards so you
try and scavenge the wastelands to
survive
no no I'm just saying people really love
the game yeah oh my God
what's the what's the big deal right
yeah worst case scenario it's gonna be
just like Fallout you're gonna go into
the uh where do you go into the Lincoln
Land no there's a building in DC where
you get the Lincoln's repeater I can't
remember what it is but whenever I start
Fallout 3 I immediately go into there's
a government building you've got to
stealth pass some ghouls ghouls are like
radioactively burned people and then you
open up this case and Lincoln's uh
Winchester repeater is in there it's an
excellent excellent weapon in the video
game so I'm just saying you know they're
saying uh it's peace is dangerous yeah
yeah this is not the pitch to get people
to be all in on nuclear war you gotta
have them play Fallout 3 and then be
like now wasn't that fun that could be
real life you could be eating moldy
cheese off the ground but yeah real this
time drinking out of toilets is another
thing you do in the game and then you
get radio radiation poisoning thing but
but too much radiation poisoning and you
get super powers
absolutely just just so mind-boggling I
saw this thing in this I I saw this
article and I was like I need the shirt
don't nuke me bro because we need this
message out more than anything else
right now because it's absolutely
ridiculous the guardian wrote an article
today talking about how the West is
making plans to avoid Panic if Russia
uses a nuclear bomb that that that's an
absolutely crazy goal post line that
we're at right now that that is
absolutely ridiculous and according to a
lot of military strategists and even
Intelligence Officers they're saying
that it's between a 10 to 25 chance that
Russia will use a nuclear bomb now the
people in charge a lot of the very
powerful people a lot of the people who
control a lot of the multinational
corporations the big Banks they have
their bunkers they have their survival
of food they have everything that they
need they don't have to wager our risk
anything else everyone else is going to
be paying for the consequences of this
for the these stupid policies and
decisions that don't have any objective
what's the goal here why are we doing
this what's the objective why can't we
even ask and why is the corporate U.S
Western media trying to Gaslight us into
a full all-out world war it's simple
pull it up Serge
could a small nuclear war reverse global
warming from The Huffington Post the
article is real February 26 2011. it
says quote nuclear war could reverse
global warming boom you are the carbon
they're trying to reduce that's because
it will end life on Earth
understand it will obliterate life and
human beings from from ever existing
like life as as we have it right now
we'll be over it'll be terrifying and if
you're lucky to survive you're going to
suffer this is so stupid and so
backwards and again you don't have to be
pro-russia Pro pool and to call for
peace and de-escalations and with
negotiations no one's always going to be
perfectly happy no one's always going to
get what they want but at least for
Frick's sakes come to the table and
start talking just to each other and
have you guys seen the pictures in
certain Subways where they're putting up
posters like how to survive nuclear
Awards yeah are they serious
I think they are who really know we have
tsas in New York City yes funded by the
city more than one though I saw the
other one uh I saw one of them there
might be more it's the woman saying like
stay inside I think I've seen that one
take a shower but that's conditioning
right it's like kind of just getting
people used to the idea which is she's
like the big one hit don't ask us how or
why and the best part is like the advice
they give you will not save you right
yeah
look look
so if you are in the blast radius I have
good news you won't even know what
happened the the Shockwave thermal
radiation detonation will kill you
faster than your brain can process
anything is happening you might hear a
whistle and then all of a sudden you
don't exist anymore now there's a
problem there's multiple layers to the
blast and you can be in just the um
there's a blast radius non-thermal which
is going to burn you and it's going to
like your ears will probably be bleeding
windows will be shattered you may be
seriously injured that's the worst place
to be and depending on the kind of bomb
they use some have maximum radioactive
yield you could be like watching
yourself melt in the fireball for like
an extended period of time so this PSA
really is for people who are outside the
blast radius completely and when they
say take a shower that's actually good
advice if you are covered in dirt and
grime you want to get clean as soon as
possible because the particles from the
radiation like the radioactive particles
iodine and things like that will get all
over you gotta take potassium iodine
pills but what they're basically saying
is if you live in like probably Harlem
or what's another good spot probably
Coney Island in that area or or Long
Island do these things because if you're
in Brooklyn Queens or Manhattan and they
nuke that's where it's going to be well
good I won't even know what happened
before I went on how it's probably going
to be Texas so that's really great well
yeah yeah I said at least I said it's a
good thing we don't live in some major
urban center like you know Austin or
whatever and I'm just like sweating like
okay well it's not just the radiation
it's the breakdown of society of
infrastructure of Clean Water of food
it's it's the nuclear fallout that of
course will be affecting the soils for
the thousands and thousands of years and
over the weekend I actually watched a
documentary about soldiers in the United
Kingdom that were experimented on by
their government that launched a nuclear
weapon
um and they brought in the soldiers just
to see what would happen to them they
made them sign contracts and ndas and
they classified a lot of this
information so if they spoke out against
what happened to them they would be
charged which treason a lot of these
soldiers died a lot of these soldiers
became infertile a lot of these soldiers
came down with sicknesses and illnesses
that you can't even imagine and this is
a U.S sorry the UK government an
official military taking their soldiers
being like yeah we're just going to put
you right in front of this nuclear
nuclear blast to see what happened to
you and they were describing how during
the nuclear blast when they put their
their their hands in front of their face
to cover their eyes they could see every
bone every blood vessel in front of
their hands wow so so you this is what
governments do they routinely sacrifice
people they sacrifice their own people
they murder they do horrific scientific
experiments and if you think the
sociopathic monsters are are not trying
to start a nuclear war you're not paying
attention because that's exactly what
they're doing every single day right now
and there's like really interesting
Fallout that goes like by Generations
too because I watched a clip on the
plane actually here and there was a guy
who was around nuclear testing and he
didn't have any issues but he had a
daughter like born after he was involved
with it and the daughter by age 11 it
took 11 years for things to show up
started growing hair all over her face
and body uncontrollably because it
messes with your genes right so it's
like it just twists the Gene and uh she
actually died after that wow oh so it's
his daughter you know I was I was
thinking like maybe you know maybe you
become like a Hulk you know what I mean
well I'll be on the good end but I don't
know maybe uncontrollable rage monster
who can't like you know have normal life
I guess I don't think that ever happened
to anyone opposed to radiation Tim oh
well you know not yet not yet I mean we
might have a someone grew hair all over
her body I mean that's kind of like a
that's the Beast there you go yeah so
one X-Man came from Wolverine that's the
one looking at this conversation in like
six months and like oh remember when we
were talking about this before it all
went oh my God
oh my God we're gonna be sitting in
rubble eating cold beans being like
remember when we made that joke and I'll
just be gone because it's gonna be in
Austin well so the point I was making
before the show about Austin was not
literally Austin but I was like
the first if we're dealing with like a
retaliatory strike or a threat then
Russia or whoever probably Russia will
not Target DC or a major city first
they'll Target a small town first for in
a shocking off strike so if you hit a
big city the rest of the country says of
course
if you hit a small town then everyone in
the country panics stops working locks
down or flees and that destroys the
economy outright right so that's
probably why they would do us a lower
yield strike on a small City first I
don't think it would be DC simply
because that would be like deciding to
shoot someone in the bulletproof armor
it's you know it's like the probably the
most heavily fortified with bunkers
Raven Rock has got a 100 million dollar
expansion have you guys heard we talked
about this yeah
that uh we had when we had Drew Miller
and he mentioned that they're doing
expansion in Mount weather which is
nuclear bunker as well as and then he
mentioned Raven Rock I looked it up just
recently in August a 100 million dollar
contract to Raven Rock for a massive
expansion and they also did another uh
award another contract for Mount weather
for a major 65 000 square foot facility
they're not going to be done right away
but they're certainly thinking about
expanding their bunkers I would imagine
all of the surface-to-air missiles and
anti-nuke capabilities are centered
around DC specifically for this reason
so they'd probably hit if they wanted to
cause major disruption in this country a
major economic Center the reason why
Austin makes a lot of sense is because
the gigafactory is there like uh so
you've got San Francisco which would be
a huge Target probably because of the
tech sector and then you've got the move
over to Austin with gigafactory and
other you know let's just call it the
California brain drain to Texas and
Florida would make them Target as well
hit the economic centers they would
probably hit the North Dakota Frack
Fields seriously hindering our ability
to produce energy those are going to be
huge targets but it's not like the
political epicenter is is is
it's probably a moderate Target but
thinking about like January 6 these
people thought that like by going in a
building they would have governmental
power or something they could it's like
dude it's not the 1600s so Putin Knows
Why hit DC the US government is is
digitally decentralized you need to you
need to economic and and
um Resource Centers Silicon Valley is
going to be a huge Target all of the
managerial power for all these all this
infrastructure you at Silicon Valley our
financial processing takes a major major
hit so we as a country need to be
diversifying all the stuff not just
because of the culture War but because
of the risk of hyper centralization in a
war you don't even have to do that you
just have to go to China and be like hey
stop selling them stuff then we're
screwed our big Pharma industry screwed
uh all the cheap plastic stuff screwed
and that again would would be a very
serious concept I'm hearing that Kanye's
uh new interview got taken down the
drink Champs that was the one that he
was talking about got taken down
I'm not sure I haven't seen it let's uh
I'm trying to look it up right now
that's just someone just sent me there
right now so uh anyway you know nuclear
war and all that stuff so dude what was
the official reason that we hit Nagasaki
in hiroshimo and not Tokyo Kyoto was it
that reason no no not the game you might
want to hit the capital you want to do a
smaller well a lot of Scholars argue one
it's because the Japanese were fighting
to the death two it was a kind of symbol
to show Russia and others he's asking
why not Tokyo why not tell you oh yeah
yeah so is it that you don't want to hit
the capital you want his smaller City to
spread more Panic well they were also
responsible for a lot of the
manufacturing and production of those
okay so the bigger materials and you you
know the United States took over Tokyo
and it was a huge it's one of the
biggest cities in the world yeah the
civilian casualties would be immense I
Googled it stack exchange someone
responded Hiroshima the first city was
an important Army Depot and Port of
embarkation in the middle of an urban
Industrial Area okay it's a good radar
Target and it's such a size that a large
part of the city could be extend damaged
there are adjacent Hills which are
likely to produce a focusing effect
which would considerably increase the
blast damage wow that makes sense due to
Rivers it is not a good incendiary
Target there were also four other
possible targets kokura Niagara Yokohama
and Kyoto there were three criteria
choosing targets the target was larger
than three miles in diameter and was
important Target in a large urban area
the blast would create effective damage
the target was unlikely to be attacked
by August 1945 and East small and
strictly military objectives should be
located in much larger areas subject to
blast damage in order to avoid undue
risk of the weapon being lost due to bad
placing of the bomb
interesting they say the possibility of
bombing The Emperor's Palace was
discussed it was agreed that we should
not recommend it but that any action for
this bombing should come from
authorities on military policy it was
agreed that we should obtain information
from from which we could determine the
effective effectiveness of our weapon
against this target oh they were testing
it
uh they wanted a good detonation to see
what the effects would be well there you
go huh interesting yeah they said it
Tokyo was not a strategic value
uh if Japan were to be invaded
interesting make sense yeah military
Target there you go my friends so I just
want to say this as I as I do
um with the upcoming election to all of
you 18 to 25 year olds particularly 18
to 25 year old males whether you're
trans or not doesn't matter the US
government has already said it you must
sign up for the draft no and if you
don't and so let me just say if you find
yourself as an 18 to 25 year old male
for some reason voting demographic then
I will personally applaud you for your
sacrifice as you are loaded up as Ken
and fodder in World War III by the
people you voted for so uh
congratulations on supporting the war
effort me on the other hand I'm gonna
keep saying the U.S should not be
involved in the Ukrainian conflict
particularly at this point as things
have escalated to this degree and we
need to find a path towards peace lest
you be drafted but uh these people just
you look at the polls actually let me
let me show you the polls for for the
sake of this end of the segment I'll
just show you right here that 18 to 29
year olds overwhelmingly favored
Democrats so to all of you I bid you
farewell as you go off to fight this war
for me I don't want you to be able to
get drafted so it's eight they say 18
and 25. however they get drafted right
but but when it comes to actual War they
definitely broaden the yeah so they'll
they'll buy script 50 year olds it's not
it's not it's practicality but let's
let's talk about the story this is good
news I suppose if you don't like War
it's not necessarily absolute great news
because neocons Republicans have their
War mongers as well but the New York
Times says Republicans gain Edge as
voters worry about economy time Sienna
pole finds here's what I find
interesting right now a bunch of polls
are dropping and they've mirror inverted
on their findings two weeks ago it's
like Democrats plus five knots flip
Democrats plus five and I'm like whoa
whoa how is this happening in the
Spanish of a week maybe it was all
propaganda BS and the pollsters are
lying they're really bad at their jobs
that one's true because they keep
getting it wrong or maybe Joe Biden
tried a quid pro quo with Saudi Arabia
it backfired gas prices are now
skyrocketing right before the election
surprise Biden now we're getting the
October surprise and people are saying
no and the economy it's the economy
stupid so there we go what do you think
Republicans going to take it now the
polls are shifting or are they always
going to take it or I mean or do they
lose I don't know well if Republicans
win then they'll announce that they're
in a recession right now about that yeah
well actually no that's gonna be a bad
thing because that's when things will
get really bad yeah because the media
will say now we're in recession and then
the rich people will stop spending just
get scared but it's already happening
but you're right the media won't admit
it they're going well we're not really
in a recession the the day after the
election if they announce Republicans
take the house they go oh it's a
recession by the way and they change the
definition of recession on Wikipedia
correct well they well this is this is
the interesting thing colloquially we
have always called it two periods two
quarters of negative growth but it's
never been an official governmental
definition so now they're playing a
semantic game where of course the
president's administrations have in the
past even Pelosi as recent as I think
earlier this year all defined a
recession as two quarters of negative
growth the moment it happens for
political reasons they go no no no
that's not the real definition right so
it's all Bs take a look at this though I
find this really interesting so in the
polling
likely voters 49 to 45 favoring
Republicans men 50 to 45 women 47 47 so
women are split but dudes are five
percent more Republican what I find
really interesting is that 18 to 29 year
olds 52 percent favor Democrats 30 to 44
50 favorite Democrats 45 to 64 is 38 for
Democrats and then you have 65 and older
which is 48 to 48. so the interesting
thing is the only demographic by age
which opposes Democrats is 45 to 64.
does that mean for there's more 45 to 64
year olds than 30 to 40 and then 18 to
44 year olds I wouldn't be surprised
because people aren't having kids but
how is it that 18 to 44 these two
different age groups overwhelmingly
favor the Democrats but 45 to 64 is
almost two to one Republican and that
results in a 49 lead for Republicans
over 45. is Gen xer is just a bigger
generation or something or what is that
some boomers are in there I guess
I don't know I find it interesting but
like the oldest age group gets more
lived out I don't understand yeah well I
I was pulled in this I was saying this
earlier I was actually pulled in this
I've never been pulled before I didn't
think they actually pulled conservative
well I'm I'm not a registered Republican
so maybe that had something to do with
it I'm ready no but this is all likely
voters this is all yeah yeah like you
probably said you're favoring Republican
yeah yeah how old are you I'm 39. oh
okay so I'm in that yeah I don't trust
that it's only 792 likely voters it's
like a nut it's not that good of a
sample size getting over a thousand is
typically better it's not it's not the
worst but it's low yeah but here's the
other interesting Factor this is
National this is not Swing Swing
districts
so when you look at actual swing
District polling if the national polls
are this bad and this includes safe blue
and safe red districts yo it's looking
apocalyptically bad for Democrats right
now with like a couple weeks before the
midterm election
good good news I don't know well you
know I'm skeptical of both political
parties especially with how much uh
disastrous foreign policies came from
Republicans and right Wingers all
throughout the last few years there is a
battle within the party so it's going to
be interesting to see how it plays out
any politician I just I I just see them
I said this before the show all as
welfare Queens I'm not a fan of any of
them is it going to really change things
maybe maybe not but I'm I'm more I'm I'm
more skeptical I do believe the real
change is going to happen with
individuals losing faith in the
institutions and becoming more
personally responsible for themselves
and making the right decisions with
every small action that they make
whether it's their thoughts whether it's
their dollar whether it's their vote and
I think truly on a local level it's
going to matter a lot more so is this
going to matter is this going to change
our perspective I don't know I see the
Baseline Republican party going along
with you know the the the coveted
policies the the war policies and I
don't see much changing from it to be
honest with you I mean I kind of feel
like there's at least enough good
Republicans who are running who are
going to block a lot of these efforts
the issue is half the Republican party
is establishment chills even if the
Republicans get a majority those
Republicans will vote with Democrats in
favor of War and the house will keep
funding all this stuff yeah the Lindsey
Grahams the Mitt Romney's uh are
definitely peculiarly are Republicans to
say the least uh but there hasn't really
been a full shift and there's been a big
pushback against a lot of the populist
Republicans that actually do talk about
what people want and need and and talk
about the changes that would actually
make a difference here but to me you
know I'm just a skeptical skeptical
person so I could just be too
pessimistic are you guys optimistic or
pessimistic there is the new wave of
like the Kerry Lakes coming up and that
looks hopeful but I mean yeah
traditionally like Republicans don't
ever really do [ __ ] when they're in
power so it doesn't exactly make me
hopeful to see that and think things are
going to change but interestingly though
oh sorry they're kind of the party that
just sits on their butt 100 I'm sorry
but our our our populists are very
Against The Establishment and speaking
out against us as you said of course the
establishment still in the way but look
at the left look at their so-called
populace like the the progressives the
squad people yeah they just fall right
in line you know if you had a coalition
between the aocs who should be against
this kind of stuff and the Marjorie
Taylor greens who knows what could be
accomplished but they're they're whipped
by Nancy Pelosi and
there you have it yeah it's gonna be
their fault we're going to war it's
gonna be the populace left you know I
kind of feel like there's a strong
possibility Pelosi won't be in office
after this yep well maybe the
speakership I don't know is she she's
not planning on retiring she said she's
running for re-election right yeah yeah
I believe so and then there's no way she
loses in that District but I wonder I
don't know if she'll be speaker
that that's I'm just hearing scuttlebutt
that it sounds like
you know for
the Democrats they're not expecting that
to be to be Pelosi is it because she's
going to pass away or something like
that why do you think what's the reason
no because we're probably gonna win
Republicans win they'll just they'll
vote for somebody else so uh but we'll
see I mean does that mean it's Kevin
McCarthy I don't know I'm just hearing
some scuttlebutt behind the scenes that
it sounds like preparations are like
there's an expectation I just put it I
can't I don't want to you know without
any Source or anything but it sounds
like there's expectation that she will
not be speaker at the very least and
maybe not even be in office although
that seems like a longer shot it just
seems like she's not going to be speaker
of the house it's going to be
interesting to see uh because it's
definitely a very fast-changing
political landscape Anything Could
Happen we're still you know in October
there could be a lot of surprises coming
our way I think there will be uh it's
already been an absolutely crazy news
cycle I think it's only going to get a
lot crazier from here oh man you know
that's the thing we're we talked about
this before October surprises how many
October surprises have there already
been Tulsa quits the Democratic party
launch a show right in October so they
want they want uh six months in jail for
Steve Bannon they're pushing and 200 000
fine what else do what else Herschel
Walker was it oh yeah yeah abortion
thing yeah yeah yeah it's just it's it's
like a machine gun of October surprises
just not gonna stop
I wonder if they tried to make the Roger
Stone thing one like just hoping people
would fall oh yeah the Roger Stone thing
yeah that was crazy we'll talk about
that one in a second too but we've got a
whole bunch of October surprises and I
wonder if any of it really messed oh the
Nancy Pelosi thing where she's like this
yourself
I can't believe they thought that was
that supposed to be good for Democrats
yeah Nancy Pelosi saying she was waiting
for trespassing at the Capitol that like
like she wanted it to happen I mean they
loved it though if you look at like all
the blue check Libs posting about it
they were yes queening about it yeah
but she's saying she expected it to
happen right I had a camera crew yeah
that's interesting
what's the official story for why she
had a camera crew does it even bother
thinking of an excuse it's just it was
there I don't understand yeah well a lot
of people expected a lot of problems and
a lot of people yeah there's a lot of
protests there was a lot of websites
there was a lot of people saying yeah
we're gonna go do this and we're going
to college trouble so I I absolutely she
was ready she she's the queen of Insider
information so you gotta understand she
knows
Warren Buffett doesn't even know right
so she's a very powerful lady with a lot
of money with a lot of influencers in
the Game of Thrones they have that uh
that Minister part of the Round Table
that's the the minister of Whispers
that's pretty much Nancy Pelosi that's
who she is yeah uh she she knows
everything before it even happens so
obviously that's a really good idea for
a skit maybe Sheamus could do this one
for Freedom Tunes where it's like it's a
carnival and you go to Plants you go to
palancy like what I call her Clancy you
go to Pelosi's she's got like a cart and
you go inside it and she reads your
fortune tells you the future you should
invest in Tesla right now why yes trust
me
then she turns around and she's like I
vote Yes on the bill to support more
Tesla funding and then it's like the
people are like wow she was right I made
a fortune she's a psychic that's how it
goes man I'm impressed that she keeps
doing like you no matter how many times
anyone complains about it be on the left
the left hand the right are complaining
about these these these Congress people
senate or house who who just make all
the right bets yeah right when they need
to make it happen for some reason right
yeah yeah and there's little support on
Banning uh members of Congress from from
trading on most I wonder why absolutely
or regulations or accountability or some
transparency no there's so many like
viral Tech talks people just investing
exactly what Nancy Pelosi does and just
because they counts apparently yeah did
they really yeah that's so disgusting
Wow Let's talk about this Roger Stone
video we have a story from Insider new
video shows Roger Stone warning Trump
will get his brains beaten if he runs
for president again so here's here's
here's what I see let me see if I where
do I have this tweet okay that's not it
where did I put the tweet
uh so here's a tweet from Christopher
goldbranson it says footage from January
20th 2021. Stone supports impeaching
Trump run again and you'll get your
effing brains beaten what you could
notice right here is I as I froze
actually let me just play the actually I
don't know if I can play the video
because he swears a lot yeah a lot a lot
but in the video and then it also makes
a threat you notice you can't see his
mouth his hand is covering his mouth and
he's saying like I'm gonna come out in
support of impeachment I saw this video
on Twitter I didn't know about the
greater context but I noticed it looked
really weird and then I noticed let me
let me see if I can zoom in
I noticed something when I was watching
it take a look at this as I play it
slowly look at his mouth
you can't really see it can you and then
we get to this point near the end and
just wait for it
and there it is and uh boom right there
his mouth is gone
I understand video artifacting it
happens but when I watched this video
without any context I saw that and it
looked really strange to me because
nothing else but his mouth artifacted
nothing else it's perfectly just on his
mouth nothing else usually you get
artifacting it's not going to be so
specific now you can argue it's just a
low quality grainy video but I saw that
and I was just like where did his mouth
go why does his mouth just outright
disappear right there like what about
the footage makes it just vanish
typically when you like like I mentioned
artifacting doesn't isolate on a
specific location when everything else
is moving in the scene Roger Stone later
claimed it was a deep fake
and he's had another deep fake video
conflating my statements about Biden
with Trump I don't know any of that I
don't know who Christopher gold Branston
is and why I should believe he is a
journalist of credibility or Merit right
well this footage was actually provided
to the January 6th panel and uh where's
his mouth Roger is saying that it's a
deep fake but this was allegedly after
uh Donald Trump told Roger Stone that
he's not going to get a pardon and Roger
Stone allegedly blamed Ivanka Trump and
Jared Kushner for this and when we look
at Ivanka Trump and Jared Kushner they
did represent more of the establishment
wing of his political Administration
um and you know this this doesn't look
good whether it's fake or real Roger
Roger Stone says it's fake
um I don't know I'm not an expert on
this particular you know aspect but when
you look at the basic story you know it
kind of adds up is it real is it not I
don't know look at this just just look
at this like that doesn't look real why
if he's going going to say a word does
his mouth vanish for no reason like that
and the fact that even when his mouth is
moving his hand is covering it almost
the entire time exactly like how
convenient that's very weird and my
mind's kind of blown because when you
showed me this before you went what's
the next frame just go back and forth
between I did look yeah his mouth is
there as part of the shot then it just
disappears and then you get that
it looks weird look at that right there
anyway we came back version of this no
this is the version this is this is the
version that went has got the million
views maybe it's real maybe I'm just you
know weird but look right there see how
his mouth doesn't line up with his cheek
yeah I don't know man maybe I'm just
making fun of Roger Stone for being ugly
maybe it's a real video you know what I
mean
ugly doesn't make your mouth disappear
and you could maybe argue it's just low
low resolution footage and it's an
artifact but look man I edit videos all
day every day for only the mouth
disappear in that one frame watch the
frame from from this Frame to the next
the only thing that artifacts is the
mouth
I just think that's very weird and I
think that is a deep fake it's kind of
scary because Insider here is reporting
it as facts yeah I'll tell you this if
watching this and trying to be
factual to the best of my abilities my
response is I don't know however if I
was working privately as someone who's
been editing video for I'm going on 24
or five years I've been working in uh
digital video editing since I was like
12 years old I was editing videos
working flash animations designing
websites and things like that if someone
privately came to me and said this video
real I'd say my opinion would be no
right as someone who's trying to report
facts I have no idea like if I can't
give you a definitive statement I would
just say I don't know but my personal my
professional opinion having worked with
video I have uh I have friends who do
composite manipulation we do some of
this stuff for cast castle with the
weird effects this to me looks like they
manipulated his mouth or he could be a
lizard person that's shape-shifting
right now right in the frame of this
video I'm joking right I just want to
make sure it's clear it's entirely
possible it's legitimate real footage
and Roger Stone is just trying to weasel
out but I have a few questions if that's
the case why would Roger Stone be
embarrassed about something he willfully
set in front of a camera crew that he
invited to be in front of him right yeah
this isn't an undercover video they're
doing a shoot right I mean they're with
him the whole time yeah why would he now
go oh no they recorded me when I chose
for them to be there in front of me
recording me when I grabbed my phone and
said everything
I just don't it just the whole thing
while I'm performing for a camera right
well it could be when he just got the
news he got overly emotional maybe I
don't know uh but I'm not just Playing
devil's advocate here it could be a
number of possibilities it would it
would be good if we get like a video
expert to look at the video and the
codec and to see exactly what it came
from who you get a raw video sample and
then go from there look at his mouth
look at his mouth we can't believe
anything or anybody look how his mouth
like it could just be bad video like
I'll say all right weird look at that
though like you see on the top of his
lip right there how the side of his lip
curls up you see kind of those darker
pixels around the corner right there
that doesn't look normal at all no not
at all your lips don't move like that
like
yeah it's too weird his mouth isn't
moving with his face in this Frame like
look when I watched this video before I
knew anything about it I thought it
looked really weird because you can't
see his mouth and when you can it
behaves strangely then I saw a new story
I think it was the hill or something and
I was like what and they were and then
they were like Roger Stone claims to
deep fake and I was just like
yeah that's weird well if it's a deep
fake it's a pretty scary precedent being
set that they can just report it as
facts and they deal with their
ramifications afterwards people are also
saying look at the ear in the comments
right now and some people are saying
it's a low bit rate yeah it could be a
little bit right I mean to be honest I
don't want to what about the ear what's
the ear doing I don't know I'm just
hearing a whole bunch of people in the
chat room look at their ear look at the
ear look at the ear oh did it kind of
jump his ear or something I mean he's
got a phone pressed up against it in a
car that's moving what's strange to me
is the way his mouth moves and the way
his mouth is covered I find that like
his mouth disappears in this Frame yeah
there's one other frame you went through
that we didn't talk about where like the
mouth like connects to the background it
was really weird where I think you might
want a little past it now
I just thought right there
that looks weird
yeah it to me the list isn't too
unnatural I think it would be really
funny if it turns out the video is
totally legit we're just making fun of
him right
yeah that is a possibility here like
when I saw this what looks strange to me
is this looks like it's an anime
character's face in this in this shot
because for those that have watched
anime you'll know that they draw the
head and then the mouth is separate so
you'll see lips but the mouth moving and
the lips are like so this I don't know
you know hey look maybe we're just
making fun of Roger Stone for being ugly
okay maybe that's it that's all it is I
have no idea who's to say all I know is
if someone came to me
and asked me if I thought it was
authentic I would immediately isolate
the part where his mouth disappears and
says this doesn't look doesn't look
right
you know it it the problem with with
video it's a lot easier to check audio
because with audio you can see where
breaks happen in the in like the the
spectral analysis and things like that
with video you have the video and people
can easily be like it's Granny low-res
okay well why did he post a granny low
res he certainly filmed this in 4k
didn't he yes but he chose he chose to
post the artifacted 480 version
seriously why serious question why is
his hand covering his mouth the whole
time why did Roger Stone agree to be
interviewed and say all these things but
then deny he said them
and why did they post the low res
version oh look I don't know who
Christopher golden Branson is and I
think if you blindly trust him then I
got a bridge to sell you but it could be
legit
for all I know I don't know man
yeah what do you think you think I just
don't actually turned on Trump and
Ivanka and Jared and all that or do you
think we got a dark future out of us
where no name people you've never heard
of can post these things not risk their
reputation and that's why they do it
yeah I think that is the future right
I'm seeing more and more all the time
like even on my Instagram Discovery page
it'll be a video of like a celebrity and
it looks so real and you click it and
it's clearly not you know so it's
getting better and better which is
pretty terrifying well he didn't get a
second pardon Kodak Black did yeah but
not Roger Stone so
right so maybe he's really really mad
could be potentially he's saying that he
was talking about Biden
I know journalists do that
they'll they they look man people they
ask like should I do the interview with
you know this mainstream company I'm
like no
because they'll say something like this
um what's your least favorite food
what's your least favorite food like
makes you sick
I I I'm really put on the spot I like
the food from last night that I hated
the restaurant it was the sauerkraut
sauerkraut I'm like you need to eat more
of this yes
how does it how would you describe the
taste of sauerkraut ugh well it was like
sour but it was also like slimy it was
just nasty cold and then what they'll do
is they'll ask a different question and
edit that question in front of your
response Temple is nasty slimy cold yeah
yeah they'll be like how do you feel
about Trump oh it's just nasty and slimy
yeah cold and then you'll be like I but
I was asked a different question and
they'll say all we did was play a video
of what you actually said right yeah we
didn't we didn't take it you know now
that's an extreme example but I have
seen what happened yep yeah they play
dirty games they'll they'll take two
different quotes from you and put them
together yep side by side and then say
no no those are real quotes well here's
how you do it in print journalism you
put a comma he said comma in between
exactly so it's just so you know I was
sitting with Blair white I say 10 more
sentences and then whatever I say at the
end exactly take out the sentences put
in comma he said and then you could
that's a trick that's a legal way to get
around it in journalism that's how
that's how slimy people do it you could
say something like you know uh did you
vote for Trump did you vote for Trump
yes so uh tell me about why you voted
for Trump
uh I felt like I was stuck in a rock in
a hard place between him and Hillary
Blair then went on to say that she felt
sick slimy and cold
and that's and that's not that it's
legal six slimy cold taste in her mouth
yeah exactly yeah that she experienced
and the best part is they can even
choose not to quote you if the quote
isn't perfect they'll say Blair then
want to then went on to express extreme
disgust over a taste in her mouth yeah
because what would have been like
sauerkraut's nasty they'll just and it's
and it's true and they get away with it
and sometimes they don't even bother
like trying to lie very well because
there was a Sun article that covered one
of my videos talking about fat
positivity and the headline was like
woman says she hates fat people and I
never said that in the video I'm like
how can you even say says something I
didn't say yeah because it's an opinion
oh yeah that's the amazing thing is if
you soon be like I never said those
words they'll be like when we said says
we meant implied through through action
and words we didn't say verbatim we
didn't put quotes on it and you they get
away with it I had a news Outlet combine
two different quotes that were 10
minutes apart to make a false oh yeah
and then when they got when that when
the subject threatened to sue him they
corrected the article saying I there was
an error in my quote as if to imply I'm
the one who made a mistake
do that to me as well the Southern
Poverty Law Center they took a quote
from the beginning of my speech and then
brought another one all the way at the
end to make me sound like I was calling
for a violent revolution when I was
calling for an evolution when it comes
to people being responsible for
themselves and smart they cut all that
out it just made me sound like a violent
lunatic on their Hit List which was
absolutely disingenuous unfair and you
know illegal in many instances and they
were sued by other people successfully
uh and had to retract a lot of that
stuff they deleted their their
falsehoods on me but I made sure every
conversation I had with them I recorded
it and they were just blanket-faced that
doesn't work though people say like if
you do the interview record it no even
if you record it they're going to be
able to lie about you and your recording
proves nothing because you don't reach
Their audience your audience very fine
people's right exactly perfect example
of this you can listen to Trump saying
and I'm not talking about the white
supremacists and the neo-nazis because
they should be condemned totally and
even though if you watch the raw video
you know he he did not say these things
the media gets away with it yeah and
you're right you only reach your
audience it's like you can have a huge
following and so get lied about and
that's the narrative forever you know
because it's not your audience they say
sometimes like try and control as much
of it as you can and so my advice is if
you're if you're an expert in media
relations and
um and you have media training then you
should do the interviews and make sure
you phrase everything as perfectly as
possible to make it so they cannot do
anything typically what I'll do when I
respond to journalists is I give them
very specific legal language I know what
I'm saying and how I'm saying it I'll
break words apart from other words so
that they so
simply put
I will give a very precise legal
response very very very precise that if
they attempt to misconstrue I could
argue actual malice that's that's the
thing you do but if you don't know how
to get how to actually phrase things
without them manipulating you then
they're going to do it they're going to
say like I said Blair then expressed
this extreme Taste of disgust in her
mouth you know as we as we went on
carrying the conversation and that's
true so you have to make sure you line
everything up very very perfectly so
that if they say that you can then
respond with they have the email from me
where I explicitly laid these points out
and thus it was actual malice when they
presented that false you know narrative
even if it's their opinion if it's very
clearly in you know the opposite of what
you're saying it's it's difficult to do
but I do weird things where I answer
questions with like very strange
sentences that will convey the idea but
don't speak well
so you'll notice um if you watch the
last show with Ian he was reading a
quote from someone from Biden I think
yeah it was a quote about from Biden
about Obama and he said
he said uh Biden said it's great that we
have Barack Obama and this is Biden
saying it that he's veriticulate and
this is again Biden saying it and that
Obama is the first clean again Biden
saying it African-American Biden said
that doing something like that so that
they can't quote you without including
all of that or putting a bunch of
ellipses you just make it very very
difficult for them to try and
misconstrue what it is that's like a
rudimentary way to try and they'll but
if you answer something like that they
usually will just don't even bother
trying to incorporate what you said
because it's too difficult to do but you
answer the question and then they can't
lie about it but let's jump to this next
story from new from the cut New York
turfs are boycotting Alta Beauty I'm not
ready
last week Ulta beauty featured trans
influencer Dylan Mulvaney on its podcast
the beauty of during which she sat down
with gender fluid hairstylist David
Lopez to talk about her conservative
upbringing coming out as trans and
chronicling her journey on Tick Tock I
know I can find love I know I can still
be a performer I know that I can have a
family she said I want to be a mob one
day and I mom one day and I absolutely
can featuring a trans woman on a podcast
about girlhood was apparently too much
to bear for hordes of transphobic
Twitter users who are now calling for a
boycott of the beauty company let me
pause the hashtag boycott Ulta the the
women are saying it's two adult males
discussing quote the beauty of girlhood
let me just show for you the
introduction to the podcast which is
causing outrage and we're on day 167 of
girlhood Mr Hollywood who I'm right here
Hollywood zoom in on that well like what
what was Dylan doing with putting the
hands like that and then shaking like no
no talking about girlhood no no but what
is that move is that a thing that's like
that's like the shimmy shaking your
boobs like like Mr Hollywood look at the
camera type [ __ ] yeah oh yeah well so
this this story's uh been going viral I
think this this video came out last week
now they're saying boycott Estee Lauder
because Estee Lauder also featured a
trans person and uh I don't know Blair
we'll take it away there's just like a
lot to unpack okay so first of all the
idea that it's turfs who are upset over
the Ulta video
seems pretty ridiculous I mean I get
called the turfs by the fact that I'm
trans and not a feminist which it's
transclusionary radical feminist how am
I both of those things it doesn't make
any sense
um so you know people are upset and
honestly it's because of Dylan Mulvaney
which first of all why didn't you change
your name why are you still Dylan um
second of all there's something really
creepy about like in adults claiming to
be experiencing girlhood like even if
this person is going to run with the
idea that they can become an actual
woman and even if that's the narrative
that doesn't make you a girl so it's
it's weird like infantilizing thing
that's disturbing so my look
I think this might be a troll I wish and
and and you know I don't know how you
you talk about this while trying look
I don't care if someone's gender fluid I
don't care if someone's trans people can
live their lives if they want to hang
out in fact this is interesting Blair
you brought up that you've been on the
show this is your fourth time and we've
never actually talked about any of this
stuff not once in fact in the car up
here I was like it's really cool that
they don't have me just to only talk
about transfers but like I'm ready to
finally talk about something and people
have been begging me to talk about Dylan
levini so really yeah it's one of those
things because a lot of trans people
hate it gay people hate it it's like
just the stuff that Dylan says you know
well let me play this video many of you
may have seen but this like you saw the
pushing the chest and shaking thing let
me let me let me play this video which
has been viral for some time now being a
girl and today I'm in nature
trees I love them
water lakes I love them
heels they're my hiking heels I love
them okay so we'll just we'll just go
step actually let me play this next part
I love them okay come on
so first I'll start with the hiking
heels this is why I say I feel like this
is a troll women don't do that this is
not girlhood there's there is nothing
about wearing high heels while hiking
women go hiking all the time they have
boots you go to the you go to the REI
and they have a women's section for
athletic boots what about being a girl
means you wear high heels in the
wilderness well this is a sexist's idea
of what we're going to do right so it's
that's the thing about wokeness is it
always comes full circle it's like we're
gonna erase stereotypes and people are
more than the sum of their stereotypes
and now it's back at the point where
it's like actually we are all just
stereotypes like this I understand why
people think this individual is making a
mockery or trolling them because like
we're not seeing people rag on you over
things like this I know people that know
Dylan and it's not a troll it's a real
person no I know Dylan's a real person
no I mean like it's not like they really
do identify as trans and this is their
like really disgusting childish view of
what that is are you sure because
there's another video released by uh
Dylan literally talking about how we
have to normalize women having bulges in
their pants as they wear tight pants hey
so that seems like a total job but also
also another big part of the boycott uh
boycott rage was that Dylan Mulvaney did
a video with a bunch of tampons like a
handful yeah like like a like a novelty
amount saying that you know they've been
carrying them around for a long time but
don't need them and then refers to
women's junk as Barbie pouches and but
like oh my God no no but like
what we're seeing let me play this again
I want you to listen to this I hiking
heels I love them okay come on
that laugh I'm gonna have an aneurysm
like
this is maybe maybe they're genuine and
that's just who they are and okay but
you know all of these things together
which are seemingly intended to be as
offensive as possible to women like the
end of this video is let me let me let
me jump to it where Dylan Falls bug
watch
oh
Falls over
[Music]
very fake gotta get out of here like
you're wearing heels in the woods is not
a thing women do
like like and what's that outfit too is
that like a workout
a workout bra and underwear what is this
what is he wearing so I I suppose what I
guess I guess what I'm trying to say is
women aren't scared of bugs there is a
stereotype of women being scared of bugs
but there are many women who go hiking
they're they're I Googled famous female
uh entomologists there's like tons of
women who've made major discoveries and
with insects this just seems like Dylan
is trying to insult women uh by engaging
in the most extreme and offensive
stereotypes possible I'd liken it to
someone putting on blackface and then
screaming about Fried Chicken but I'm
not trying to be I'm not trying to be
mean I'm trying to call it someone I
think is intentionally trying to be
offensive like I'll say it again wearing
high heels in the woods is a joke like
that's not a real thing you know I don't
think Dylan's like trying to offend
people I think Dolan is just such a
narcissist that it's just like you know
this person went viral on Tick Tock they
had this huge following I think it's
just this is Dylan being a narcissist
not Karen and what how it looks right so
it's the over top over the top like
caricaturized like oh a bug and falling
and acting stupid right it's like the
stupid woman stereotype so yeah it's
just such a narcissist he doesn't care
how it affects people I think that's at
the beginning of the ultimate video he
said this is day 150 of girlhood so he's
newly transitioned and how Dylan got
like famous was documenting day one day
two day three and these like really
stupid videos
um so yeah like who does this help right
it helps Dylan because it gets followers
and whatever but like yeah yeah it
pisses off women definitely pisses off
trans people it just hurts everyone
and the Ulta thing I think we were
talking about earlier how it's really
it's like the market has kind of capped
with women buying Cosmetics it's like
now they have to sell to males that's it
right there that's the answer right the
reason why I think they do the beauty of
so look capitalism is why you are going
to see more and more of this and there's
nothing you can do to stop it
even with the Ulta boycott it's very few
women who are going to do it the average
woman says I don't care about politics I
just need you know Foundation 122 or
whatever number it is I don't know we've
got we've got a bunch of makeup because
for people to show when they want to
cover stuff up so we have all the
different I don't even know anything
about it but we went to like we went to
Dollar General I just grabbed a thing I
said there you go now we got makeup we
have a makeup department but so the
average woman goes to Ulta and just says
I need Foundation they're not going in
about did you see the latest podcast
with Dylan Mulvaney what this does do
however is for gender non-binary people
for Trans people they are expanding
their market share Ulta and Estee Lauder
and these other companies are like we
have maximized the amount of money we
can make what do we do well we can
release a new top of the line
eco-friendly version it's like we've
done that over and over again what if we
sell to men men don't wear makeup what
if we create a culture around males
actually wearing makeup surprise
surprise big YouTubers that are males
who wear makeup be they trans or gay or
just for like there are just straight
guys that are you know Metro or whatever
they call it who wear makeup this is a
this is a Maxima maximum market share
opportunity for Ulta they're probably
having meetings saying we don't care
about the culture we care about can we
sell more and now we can we have just
opened up half the population that we
were missing before yeah it's true and
there are like tutorials on YouTube for
like how to wear like straight man
makeup it's like they're really
expanding it you know but I'm gonna I'm
gonna invest in the in the beard
trimmers for women uh industry very soon
now right there's a pro athlete recently
who started a makeup line a male really
it was a Yankees player or someone male
makeup I mean male makeup has been a
huge thing in Korea and K-pop season for
a long time yeah that's true yeah yeah
there you go yeah don't mess with K-pop
fans either when we're talking about
anime fans you're talking about that I
was like dude don't touch the padded
underwear yeah women got padded bras
boys it's time to get that padded
underwear and chicken cutlets exist
chicken cutlets yeah you don't know what
chicken cutlets are no no that's you
know how much in your bra yeah Women
fake dudes yeah chicken cutlets yeah
they have like literal they kind of look
like chicken
oh but like it's like it's like yes
oh right right the woman looks like
she's more busty oh like in uh the
misery misery business music video you
know Paramore oh yeah and they rip it
out she pulls them out of the girls bra
I'm starting the woman scape business
this is official I needed a company I
needed a product woman Escape right now
we're doing this anyone in the mail
sculpting industry hit me up right now
and we'll do this you know what's
interesting about the Ulta thing though
is that they had the comments turned off
and then they turned them back on
there's a bunch of hidden replies but I
think they got dragged so hard for
hiding them now they're allowing them
but I mean it's Bleak it's like no one
likes this stuff and the blanket you
know phrasing that it's all turfs that
are upset about it it's like I don't
think even 20 of people who are
complaining about it know what a Turf is
right yeah there's I've seen a bunch of
videos from just like run-of-the-mill
college age women being like two adult
males talking about girlhood is
offensive it's the weirdest thing to me
though in the hierarchy of Oppression
that like women are now basically off
like women throughout history they you
know they say patriarchy all these
things and all of a sudden you've got
biological males talking about girlhood
and when a woman speaks up the woman is
the problem well this is the problem
with the Trans movement in general and
why like I learned very early on even
despite being trans that I didn't want
any part of it you know it's like it's
not just about you for these people it's
about everyone else as well so it's not
just enough for Dylan to be like this is
me it's like Dylan saying this is me and
it doesn't matter how far I take it
everyone just has to be cool with it you
know like there used to be this goal
within the trans community of like an
integration into society and it's the
exact opposite now now it's this
adversarial relationship and it's a
movement that poses a threat to women
and children now which I don't think any
movement that even is perceived that way
yeah can survive well I I think you know
thinking on a deeper level in my own
personal opinion the last few years
there was a psychological emotional and
physical war against men and I think
that war was very successful and it
destroyed manhood masculinity
testosterone sperm levels you name it
the modern man has been pretty much
subjugated and destroyed now I think the
agenda is moving up towards women and I
think the same thing is happening to
women right now and we're seeing the
early phases of this larger
psychological mental physical and uh
emotional attack that they're going
through do you think one solution Luke
might be that men should sunbathe their
testicles uh well you got to be careful
giving too much heat on your balls
because it's actually bad this is a
Tucker Carlson reference does it work
yeah I actually did a video about this
on my own whole members area should you
suntan should you red light your balls
short and sweet of it I'm not gonna make
you go there and watch it just to get
the answer no because it's too much heat
and too much heat on on your balls it's
not good for you this is why a lot of
people say you know holding a laptop in
your lap is actually really bad for you
especially when it comes to your
reproductive organs keeping your balls
cool is actually what you should be
doing and what a lot a lot of fertility
doctors are selling them to do so you're
saying skinny jeans is a conspiracy by
Bill Gates to reduce the population
could be I don't know if it's by Bill
Gates it's probably by the fashion
industry which is connected to a lot of
people who love to go on that island
that we love to talk about Mr Epstein's
Island so so the fashion industry again
a lot of the top people Victoria's
Secret you name it all those fashion
Moguls there's a reason I think
personally they try to make their models
look like little young boy
um I I think there's a there's a reason
for this specifically there's a big
connection to a lot of very Sinister
really bad people but but yeah men have
been essentially de-masculated you know
just just kicked out just just destroyed
I think now we're seeing the beginnings
of the destruction against uh women and
you know I wore skinny jeans as a kid
and not look at me so wow
just saying I don't I don't see any of
this going away because no there's more
money to be made than lost it's just
that simple
yeah like think about anything any kind
of product that has it has a small
market share and you will see them try
to expand it this is what we've been
seeing across the board the reason why
you know Disney is trying to do uh
diversity is it's not because many of
the younger employees are probably fully
into the die cult but a lot of the
executives are just like we're not
making enough money
like we've capitalized the white
Suburban mom Market how do we get these
other markets and it's like well you've
got to make products for those markets
so this is why there's a conspiracy
theory that there's a mixed race agenda
because all commercial like almost every
commercial now she's a mixed race family
yeah it is not because they're trying to
get people to mix to race mix it's
because they're trying to make one
commercial with one budget that will be
like that will cater to a black person
and a white person at the same time the
problem is it ends up just being
alienating for everybody because people
don't relate to these these like you do
a commercial where it's a family in a
suburb regardless of race with granite
granite countertops and they're pouring
bowls of cereal or making rice krispies
treats together that is meaningless to
people who live in cities that is not a
relatable experience doesn't matter what
your race is but a lot of people are
conspiracy of this we'll see that and
they'll be like they're trying to
convince us to to have interracial
relationships and it's like bro I think
that might have been like 60 something
years ago right now they're just trying
to not spend money on marketing that's
that's the that's the real conspiracy
and what better way to Market than to
start up controversy than to have
everyone talk about oh absolutely it's
true like elta's probably high-fiving
their marketing team right now for this
right right everyone and they're going
through a list and they're going to be
like we got this podcast is by Tim cast
IRL talked about it for 20 minutes and
they're gonna go wow good job guys and
there's something to that because it's
like as much as the video annoyed me and
it's gross and you know I maybe won't
shop there for a couple weeks it's like
when this is the back of my mind just
gone in history I'll just be shopping at
all too like yeah you're gonna be like
walking down the street looking at your
phone as someone criticizes this and
then you're gonna look to your left at
Ulta and they're gonna have new shiny
cosmetic and go and then you're gonna
turn your phone off walk inside and buy
it exactly but I don't mean that like
even for you I mean like most people
it's like look at all the things Netflix
has done and I'm willing to bet tons of
people who watch would still have
Netflix so uh you had cuties cuties you
also had uh you still have big mouth
which I can't believe exists as a TV
show yeah it's about uh
or I guess pubescent children having you
know adult interactions it's like their
puberty monster right it's like they're
they're yeah it's it's it's it's
children going through puberty and them
showing it right right like naked little
girls and like you know little boys
what's the purpose yeah it's it's funny
to them I guess I I don't know is it
like a reality like documentary it's a
cartoonist cartoon it's a cartoon it's a
cartoon where the characters are voiced
by adults it's on like season seven or
something and they've been subject to
repeated controversies one where it had
like 12 year old girls cartoons mind you
but naked walking around in a bath house
with a bunch of other naked women
singing about why their bodies are
beautiful and the left was like it's
body positivity it's fine and people
were like why are they making a show
about sexualized children then they came
out with cuties it's not the first time
they've done this but despite all of
this I'm willing to bet a ton of people
who listen to the show and agree that
it's bad still have Netflix accounts I
personally don't I tell other people not
to have it other people I know who work
here they've got them and so it's like
what are you gonna do here's what I have
even say become a member at timcast.com
smash the like button all that stuff
however I know that it's not completely
reasonable to tell everybody to just
cancel their entertainment despite the
fact that Hulu Netflix Amazon evolving
these bad things
people want the shows that are good are
the shows that are bad but in the end
the money that that you pay ends up
going to the bad stuff so what we're
trying to do is we're trying to make
culture and make content and it's just
not easy we're competing with
multi-billion dollar corporations and we
are a company of like 30 people but I'm
hoping that with the daily wire is doing
with what we're doing and of course many
others eventually people will just be
like I don't want Netflix for political
reasons but I also don't need Netflix
because these other platforms are
creating something that's entertaining
enough for me right I'm surprised there
was a show on Netflix actually promoting
people going through puberty at all
because usually they're trying to like
block people now well yeah you're trying
to create new customers with getting
meant to buy makeup I mean when you're
convincing kids to become trans you're
talking about millions of dollars per
patient well yeah the money is also in
that too and there's a conversation
about big Pharma you know trans
surgeries it's going to become like a
billion dollar industry now and like
what better way than to include kids you
know when historically that's just not
the case it was always like one or two
one-offs in Sweden or one of these
Progressive European countries and now
it's like kids in Texas the end result
of so much of this whether intentional
or not is population reduction yeah so
you know you can argue as a conspiracy
theory to do it I don't know about any
of that I don't know their intentions I
know Bill Gates has said he wants to
reduce population growth but all of
these things
even War less people yeah yeah let's go
to super chats if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share this
show take the URL post it wherever you
can be the notification people are
pointing out that they're not getting
notifications anymore so you can hit the
notification Bell or just be it be the
notification post it on social media
send messages to your friends it helps
us out when you uh spread the show via
word of mouth so we really do appreciate
it and become a member at simcast.com
because we're gonna have that very spicy
uncensored members show coming up at 11
p.m should be fun
all right ferret man says did you guys
watch oddballs as I had mentioned on
Thursday in my Super Chat what'd you
think of it I looked into it I didn't
watch it
um I think we were sharing it in our in
our company chats and people were like
some people had watched it I didn't
watch it but I saw uh like
the gist of it a little bit so I don't
know I don't know have you guys seen it
apparently fauci's the bad guy in one of
the episodes like it's an illusion to
voucher or something whoa yeah you know
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim when I was
growing up the 90s as a young girl I
wish they were meant to explain to me
what I was going through and how to use
my Barbie pouch right
it wasn't like mansplaining some concept
like two years ago
what is this
yeah this is the definition yeah yeah
quite literally it's
all right Gaff says the 80 mortality
rate was in mice down from 100. the
story said that when they gave the
Omicron to the mice none of them died
and when they gave the Omicron S 80 died
so are are you are you saying that the
alpha strain killed them 100 but the
Omicron s modified was only 80 like
either way it's a really bad highly
infectious virus I guess 80 is correct
Jack Bailey says Tim what brand of
clothes do you wear I want to dress up
like you for Halloween so I can draw my
students into your right wing world
that's what the Daily Beast wrote they
wrote 10 pools using Maga butt Rock to
lure people into his right-wing world or
whatever not Mega butt Rock
coming out November November 4th overtly
political meant to be somewhat offensive
to The Establishment so I'm excited for
that but uh but yeah we'll close over I
don't know
um the pants are Volcom solver
uh what shoes am I wearing I'm wearing
uh are these the Jocelyn's I'm wearing
Chris joslin's shoes I'm I'm Etnies
they're some of the best sketches I've
ever worn to be honest Chris Johnson he
knows what's up with his shoes for sure
and um uh I don't know there's a shirt I
got of Amazon I shouldn't buy it there
Ian yells at me he's right too as well
see that's another point I complain
about this stuff and Ian points out we
don't wear American clothes we buy our
garbage from Amazon I'm like you're
right that's true granted Drew I did buy
all these shirts well before he he made
me realize that I haven't bought any
sense so I will try my best or I will
say definitively moving forward any new
stuff I buy I have like 500 shirts so
this shirt I'm wearing I think I have
like 60 of them people don't people
don't understand
um
when you're filming stuff I'll tell you
why I wear the same thing I have like
three outfits I wear all the time
when I would when you go out to film
documentaries when you're going when
we're filming cast casts or whatever if
I'm gonna be in it it is super annoying
when it's like you've got to go change
your outfit because it doesn't match
what we filmed previously I would travel
on shoots for vice and they'd be like
only they would say buy five of the same
shirt because we need you need to wear
the same thing every day for continuity
in case we have to put something from
the end an interview before a different
interview so I'm just like okay I just
wear the same thing every day so you're
lucky if I wear the same thing twice
people are like oh are you broke now
I suppose
yeah but hey shout out on November 4th
we have a new song coming out we're
really excited for it we think it's
going to do really well because it's
overtly political heavily uh critical of
what's going on in the world war The
Establishment uh the media all that
stuff so um should be good and then
we're going to be doing a music video
which I think might get us suit but you
know hey goodness we're gonna do it
anyway let's do a song with Tom McDonald
I talked to him yeah he's just a busy
guy you know but Tom uh big fan he just
came out with the song sheeple it was
really good yeah he's the best nicest
guy too yeah and you're in one of his
videos yeah he had it has 20 million
views that's the most thing I've ever
done and I'm like oh my God never done a
music video I just rolled up and did it
in like an hour I was like okay amazing
all right Jake Jones says Luke is a Fed
that is all
confirmed
all right mystery guest says would you
uh would you make an in-person exception
for PSA sich sich is the smartest
political commentator on the internet if
you don't know Tim you should know I am
familiar with PSA sitch
we only do in-person interviews uh
yeah I just I really loathe over like
digital interviews what we could do
though is a masked interview so we've
talked with some people who are
Anonymous personalities but who like
they're publicly Anonymous but privately
communicate with various journalists and
people we know and we've said if you do
want to come in person for the show
we'll just have we won't put a camera on
you so you will be in person with us we
can talk to and have a real conversation
but no one will see you and a few people
have expressed interest in doing that so
that's a possibility
but it's also some people don't want
even us to know who they are
I don't I don't I don't like digital
interviews man they just I don't know I
don't like them they don't work there's
no soul
yeah there's no like Luke putting in
balloons under his shirt and then us
having to interrupt him and stuff you
know things like that
things like that they're important
all right let's see Adam Wilbur says
filter out the base a bit more please my
subwoofer goes crazy when I play this in
the living room I don't think we do
anything to the base at all we don't but
we can we can do that slightly off but
I'll try and add a little bit to that we
don't really have any subwoofer thing
it's also hard to hear the headphones in
that way so I don't know maybe it's just
your base is too good yeah maybe you
should turn your Bass Down sounds like
you're so plowed yeah
Zach 2007 says I'm active duty and I was
called out by an official Navy Facebook
page for pushing Equity I reached out to
your company and exposed the Navy
threatening me openly would love to have
you report on it interesting
um man I don't know how to facilitate
that uh communication
other than if someone from the news team
is listening there it is
we'll have to figure out a better a
better way
director says Tim why doesn't your store
sell a beanie only a shirt with a beanie
on it that won't keep my brain warm got
the notification on my phone tonight hey
that's good news it's because Teespring
doesn't have functional beanies
that's it I've talked to a bunch of
different companies the really good
beanies that I have are like skate
beanies that you can wear in the summer
that you're meant to like they're meant
to be skateboarded in and for some
reason every company that does custom
merch even distributors cannot make them
and I'm like then where are they getting
them from yeah it's like Vietnam or
something well when Teespring adds that
that's going to be your number one box I
talked to them about it and I said
here's here's an example of some of the
hats from some of the companies and
they're like we were unable to Source
any of these and I was like okay and so
we've we get companies sending us
samples and they're just really awful
like I'm not gonna I'm not gonna wear
them or sell them just they're just not
good yeah gonk says shout out Blair for
being hot
thanks
all right culture abduction says hey Tim
love the show so much y'all are great
and do you know a channel called of
vlogging through history he knows a lot
about the Civil War and other history
topics let me uh let me write that down
vlogging through
history
there you go there we go write it down
yeah you saw him do it
Iggy the incubus says doesn't Kanye
didn't Kanye also work with Trump on the
first step act I think he might be
trying to to be more than just an artist
at this point
Maybe
maybe I don't know
all right what do we got let's grab some
more
Jake CB says doesn't bind parlor also
give Kanye a stake in parallel economy
I don't think so
that's Rumble yeah yeah besides
peps McGee says Luke gave me a shout out
last week about my wedding on Saturday
can I have a congrats about my new wife
and I love the show Nick and Denise
congratulations
absolutely congrats yeah
he's calling you up
Almighty media says Chadwick looks like
a healthy stable Hunter Biden
it's a man in there somewhere like a
non-cracked out yeah
iron heed says Joe Blair saw you and Tom
McDonald snowflakes music video also Tim
Grim Adventures of Billy and Mandy the
cookie episode the cookies were made
from Bugs no bugs no pods love all y'all
wow
oh yeah for real now check it out yeah
Tom McDonald rad big fan he uh he
released sheeple you guys should check
out you should buy it support the
support the music it's good I was really
impressed how he how he he did some of
this he
these are amazing music videos and he
his team is so small it's him his
girlfriend and like one other person wow
that's amazing yeah and you just roll up
and they
just film it it's crazy the chronicles
of Chris says did you see the story
about the former FBI cyber security
specialist who said he thinks 80 percent
of Twitter is Bots I'll believe it yeah
I absolutely believe it yeah they ban
and the reason people like I got banned
from Twitter yeah because you're a real
person
[Laughter]
yeah people don't realize they're
watching this show we're all AI
generated yeah it's a computer there's
no really really good depicts yeah
and then people get surprised and they
see me in public like I thought you were
fake no no real people real people
okay music DC guy says Ian Malcolm and
Jurassic Park had it right the
scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could they didn't
stop and think if they should oh hey
that's what I was saying that was from
Jurassic Park yeah it was I thought that
was like a grand like no whoa from like
Aristotle yeah maybe not Aristotle
because it's too well but maybe like
Oppenheimer or something yeah yeah I
believe I believe the question he said
you guys were so preoccupied with
whether you could you didn't stop to
think whether you should I think it's
like how the quilt goes I don't know
someone can correct me that's excellent
writing though can we just attribute
that to like Oppenheimer or somebody
involved he did the nuke right
I want to say so he's the one who said I
am become death I think that yeah that's
yeah yeah actually that's true funnily
enough that's true I know that from a a
funny source of mine a friend of mine
used that in like a ski video years ago
but yeah it's Robert Oppenheimer there
you go man
mechanized and weaponize says why Tom
Clancy's The Division that's why
operation dark winter directive 51.
that's the craziest thing ever
so if you guys haven't played if you
guys know about the division no so Tom
Clancy's The Division they base it off
of real things the game is a pandemic
hits New York is locked down and there's
like weird groups that have formed
factions there's a private military
contractor that's trying to reclaim
parts of the city you're you're part of
the division created by the US
government to try and reclaim parts of
the city there's a bunch of firefighters
like because they're organized became a
band of like Marauders and they actually
have Flames or something then there's
like prisoners the Rikers I guess they
form a faction and gang and go and raid
the city but uh operation dark winter is
is is basically
um I think it was a a was it what was it
a war game about a spread of a major
pandemic so they based this game on
these actual things and director 51 is
when George W bush says the federal the
executive branch has the right to to
dissolve and reinstitute a new
government
yeah and then Obama changed it and like
re-upped it I'm pretty sure it still
exists I think Trump may have added
something to it but basically it exists
so that if there's a World War the U.S
government reforms the protocol that's
what they made it but the criteria for
how they can direct when they can call
upon it it's like any substantial loss
of life anywhere in the world that
negatively impacts the us so you know
war in Ukraine yeah all right
yeah small yield nuclear weapons right
Ivan U says Tim plot stop saying yay as
ye are it's pronounced yay Kanye West
yeah it's yay I think yeah yeah nice
name though yeah yeah oh yes
someone told me that that why why he
wasn't yay they said that he was
specifically Yi like Yeezy did they
really say that someone told me like
Yeezys it's Yi I think I think it's yay
but also Yeezys am I wrong I think it's
yay yeah but also Yeezys
that's true I was saying yay first and
then someone said no it's a Yi for like
Yeezy and then I was like oh I think
I've heard him verbally say yay yeah I
think it's yay because it's just a
shortage it's Kanye yeah
it's Kanye West so when I tweeted Trump
West 2024 a Forbes reporter wrote Tim
Poole suggested Trump running a rapper
and I was like when did I say Kanye
and I was like
for all you know I was talking about
Billy West he's the voice of you know
you know Billy West is no voice actor
famous guy he's the Eminem commercials
maybe oh of course if you're gonna make
it up make up something more fun than
Kanye yeah I love how the media but it
proves my point then like the kind of
the point I was trying to make is I
didn't say who West was and West is a
generic name I could put Trump Smith and
then people would just like just pick
your Smith which one is it John Bill
Eric Diane
yeah
all right what do we got here
uh gaffes repeated it was 80 in mice
less than OG covid stop right the point
was they made an extremely more
infectious deadly version right so you
see you see what the issue was the
original strain was not as infectious
Omicron was extremely infectious so they
made OG extremely infectious it's crazy
yeah Boston please stop please stop
hey man they do it yeah Victor Snyder
says repeal the 17th Amendment and the
Federal Reserve and boomsticks for the
poor the king of Ohio has so ordered
boomsticks for the poor what guns yeah
the 17th that's the Senate right I think
that the Senate is popular vote
I don't know
that's not 20. who's the king of Ohio
okay cool
okay correct election of senators what
yeah 17 was that we did direct election
of senators instead of the state senate
uh appointed 25th state senate
appointing was a substantially better
system and they made a mistake getting
rid of it because it used to be that you
needed to know who your local
politicians were and then you had them
accountable if they sent a bad Senator
to the federal government now no one
even knows who they said senators are
and don't even vote they ignore it and
they got all these local problems man
oh the 25th is about the president yeah
yeah but Biden's feet yeah yeah do you
know Chase helicopter tour says Tim I'm
from Massachusetts little known fact in
Fallout 4 where the nuke hits and
becomes known as the glowing sea is
where the town of Sudbury is which
happens to be the home of for Raytheon
yay hey man the people behind Fallout
did a really great job with thinking
these things out like where the bombs
would hit and so
I played Fallout 3 when I was in LA I
lived in La fall 3 comes out I play it
my mind is blown one of the best games
I've ever played played that game for
hours wasted so much time the first time
I went to DC it was a strange feeling I
just was like I know where everything is
yeah because it's not like perfect but
they basically Fallout 3 is a DC map I
remember going into the subway and being
like whoa this is crazy it's the exact
Subway wow and I'm like looking at the
walls like I am freaked out because like
you know you're used to seeing video
games be not real life yeah and now I'm
in DC and I I just I could tell where
things were by playing a video game yeah
the same with like Grand Theft Auto it's
like you learn all these cities for each
franchise yeah you like no parts of LA
yeah I mean and but the maps are usually
like smaller or different in some ways
but certain areas are perfect I want to
play Fallout in Chicago like they need
to make it they did New Vegas and I was
like then they did you know they did
Massachusetts it's like okay that's cool
but you know in Boston for MIT and stuff
I'd love to see in Chicago because in
the Fallout Universe proposal fan The
Enclave has a has a holdout in Chicago
dude the writing is fantastic so
I could be getting it wrong Fallout fans
because it's been a long time since I
played it but Raven Rock is where the
government evacuates to in real life in
the Fallout story The Enclave is like
armored Advanced you know a faction and
it's the remnants of the US government
who went to Raven Rock and then come out
after the nuclear war and start taking
things over again right super amazing
man fun game I'm not as big a fan of
Fallout 4 but it's still a fun game
five against eight says yeah big Fallout
3 fan but I seem to remember dying
several times while playing it maybe
that was just me though I always play
Fallout as a sneaky sniper you just you
know High stealth and uh never get into
a fight that you didn't win before it
starts you know what I'm saying all
right Jude says just got Chad's book
then an email from HR wanting volunteers
for Dei initiative debating join observe
object but risk sanity great job and
rapport
here's my advice
I don't know Jude if you uh what your
background is but assuredly in these uh
die cult meetings they will say
something offensive about a gender or
race
when they do you now have grounds for a
complaint and I suggest you make those
complaints so the obvious one is if
you're a white person and they tried
saying things up something about white
privilege that is a racialized
derogatory comment and you can say I
want to complain about this person for
making a derogatory comment if they say
what was the comment be like I will not
repeat what they said it was disgusting
but they said it and I'm telling you
right now if it happens again I will
escalate to the EEOC they will log that
in their corporate books and they will
reprimand the HR person and say we don't
know what you did we don't care just
don't let these things happen again what
people need to understand is that when
they talk about white privilege they're
being racist period you can't do that
so you know I'll tell you this right now
there's a uh some people have told me
that's not true to him they they'll
they'll ignore you and say that you're
right wing or whatever
a Netflix executive was explaining to
staff what words were deemed offensive
and he got fired for saying the words
employees complained that he said the
offensive words in his explanation of
how you should not say them
when they called him into the HR meeting
they said we heard a report that you
made offensive you said offensive words
and he was what and they're like what
did you say he's like I explained what
words were offensive and what words were
those he said it they went oh he said it
again oh my God no joke I think it's a
2018 and they fired the guy I remember
that yep so if when you're like I don't
know if that could happen I'm telling
you man go to the meetings and
afterwards immediately file a complaint
with the person who gave the meeting and
say it was shocking they made it
racially derogatory comments this was
this a joke did you bring me in there
just to mock us I am shocked by this
I know how companies work I've been I've
been a manager of many companies I am
Telling You HR doesn't care about what
or why they'll say I don't care what
they said someone was offended write it
down and take note of it so we don't get
sued reprimand them so that we can say
in our books we took action this is why
all this stuff is happening yeah use
their own BS against them exactly and
then if they have another meeting then
do the same thing and if you have any
friends at work who agree with you on
this stuff be like any time they bring
up racial presumptions White Privilege
or otherwise you say it's a racially
derogatory comment and say they were
talking about the inherent qualities of
a particular race they were taught like
here's what I would say I'd be like I am
I am not going to repeat these foul
things but I'll tell you they were
talking about the inherent behaviors and
and worth of people based on race and I
was shocked that they were saying
certain races were better than others
that's basically what they told us
wow were you there and the best part is
if they go and sit in the next one then
you complain about them yeah then the
person you complained to the problem is
the HR person is the person you complain
to and they're the one giving the
meeting you might have to go to the EEOC
if I tell you what the government loves
this stuff
you know so it is what it is if they
want to make racial racial comments and
insult people based on race I recommend
you complain
all right
JK rain says all the rich will become
Robo brains while everyone at timcast
becomes Ghouls and becomes the GNR
gather up your rat away and stimpacts
Tim his Fallout reference no we'd be um
I don't I don't know
did uh did Fallout have Preppers
they should have I don't think they did
I don't think they did nobody nobody
played Fallout here no surge did you I
played Fallout when I was younger there
are no Preppers in Fallout are not that
I know of no yeah that's that's
surprising there should be yeah there
are people who survived obviously but
there should be like private vaults in
Fallout yeah where like weirdos have
have 100 years worth of beans right
wasn't it like wall Tech was a company
and they made all those faults and
experiments and they had different
experiments to like once that happened
and that was like part of the lore and
like you'd go and find places that yeah
yeah so in Fallout the a private company
with government subsidies builds a bunch
of Fallout shelters everyone thinks to
save them from nuclear war but in fact
most of them are just running
experiments the idea was we don't know
what the world will be like after oh
they did people are saying the free
states there did there were Partners
okay yeah people are saying uh
oh yeah so so anyway in Fallout the idea
was that after the nuclear war we don't
know what the environment will be like
so if you get a bunch of vaults to
experiment on people you increase the
likelihood humans survive after the fact
there was only like I think one Vault
that was actually normal that was
actually a shelter there was there was
one Vault with 99 women and one man and
one Vault with 99 men and one woman just
to see what would happen one Vault they
dosed the air with LSD in micro doses
yeah wow dude the game's it's a wild
game
oh yeah dude Fallout 3 is amazing you're
in DC yeah and there's like
radioactively burned ghouls they're
super mutants so they created a forced
evolutionary virus to try and make
people immune to radiation but it
created it turned them into large giant
really stupid androgynous monsters that
can't reproduce oh yeah the game's
fantastic well I'm actually down to play
this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
a first person shooter or third person
you can switch Yeah it's cool stuff you
can lock pick a computer hack it's it's
great stuff nice yeah if you like Elder
Scrolls too similar
no P says Tim covered Russian dead man
switch then claimed mad doesn't exist
maybe not for Russia but NATO well aware
of dead man loop fire from rad level
uh which dead man switch are you talking
about the the like the weird sound that
like never went away or something maybe
it's been too long I don't remember what
you're talking about
Mavis says we've already got dips dips
on being the first nuclear strike Tim
already called out Binghamton I'll let
you guys know if I get any superpowers
oh dibs it says dips well we'll see how
it plays out good luck
Immortal Legends it is a rumor that
Saudis joined brics Alliance today
um I am seeing I saw that story from uh
I think a South African Source yeah
yeah so is that true ramaphosa is the PM
of South Africa or the president
societies want to join bricks correct
for World War III baby that'll be
that'll be it Biden will lose his mind
and the American industrial complex is
the military industrial complex is just
going to be like fire the missiles yeah
cannot that happen
red neck Italian says I think you're
wrong Putin would hit the Midwest think
about past Wars manufacturing was the
only way we could win World War II we
can switch to War Machine and
mass-produce if we don't exist we can't
yeah I think you you're saying you think
I I said he would hit the Midwest like
Dubuque Iowa yeah like heart of the
Midwest yeah he's going to hit rust
Belden any kind of manufacturing he can
yeah absolutely
Adrian Contreras says Blair I love you
and you have a great arsenal but
painting your guns like you have his
criminal it's literally not though black
guns matter Blair but it's like first of
all I have black guns but it's literally
not illegal like you can pay him
whenever you want a pink purple
yeah Luke Luke wanted you to bring him
out so we can go to the range but yeah
but it's like hard to transport
especially in this area I guess in
Virginia you're okay though right I've
never flown with a gun I know it's like
not actually that hard right yeah like
you take it apart to a certain degree
like you you unload it you separate ammo
and then you put in a carry-on I guess
correct yeah but you got to make sure
you don't land somewhere where it's
illegal because they arrest you on the
spot right like really yeah like if your
flight gets diverted to New York City
you're you're screwed and you can't even
pick it up and as soon as you pick it up
or even tell the airline about it the
cops come and arrest you there's no
grace even if you didn't choose to get
off the plane no you're in possession
with a weapon oh that's insane yeah
maybe they won't fly they have cops
waiting when they know you're
transporting weapon and as soon as you
grab the bag they run up and grab you
yeah even if it's something that's
disgusting yeah even if you do
everything because you have to tell the
airline that you have a firearm and
you're checking in a firearm right um
unloaded magazine out bullets in the
original box that they came in
um that's and and a locked box but even
if you do that and say your flight has
to make an emergency landing in New York
City you can still get around
automatically yep that's demented yep
and there was cases where individuals
got diverted or or had a layover and or
or their flight got canceled uh you know
in between flights they had to pick up
their their property cops knew the
situation as soon as they touched it
automatically arrested let me not fly
with any guns yep that's why we were
like we shouldn't do that Patrick Reed
says Tim you are not accounting for the
demographic weight by age of likely
voters the older the demographic the
higher percentage are likely to vote so
older voters would get waited more on
such a poll
okay
I am just you that you nailed it but I
just want to stress again younger voters
18 to 29 favor Democrats bro sign up for
the military already if that's the case
you want to go you want to go bomb
Ukraine go for it right I'm not saying
all Republicans are perfect but at least
Trump didn't want to go to war
you know then I'm going to be sitting
back in my rocking chair and we're going
to pull out a box of cigars when these
19 year olds are like why am I being
drafted
voted for it and then I'm not
yeah enjoy it buddy I know they may
draft me at some point because I am
still a strapping young man of the age
of 36 but uh I got a ways to go before
they start pulling my age age bracket
and you know Trump was more trans
friendly because he banned me from
getting drafted and Biden's trying to
put me away no we we talked about this
too I said it was insane when they when
when so this story about uh trans people
being like drafted doesn't matter which
identify as I said that's ridiculous
like I gotta be honest if you if if I
was told that I could give a gun to one
person because we're going to combat but
I wouldn't choose you over Buck Angel
like if I hadn't gone to book you know
what I'm not the best example because I
don't think Buck Owens owns need guns I
have 10 I know a fair point Fair Point
you I know what you're saying like the
yeah like the fact that they would draft
you right I just I just I just think
that actually doesn't make a whole lot
of sense you want whoever is most
effective for it and and biological sex
doesn't determine that well it's
probably isn't it probably a precaution
because they've already set up the
environment where you are what you
identify as so if there's a draft they
don't want you know 50 million young men
being like Oh I'm actually I'm trans
like here my name's Dylan well it's
interesting the Biden administration's
official stance is like when it comes to
sports
homeless shelters than trans women or
women but like when it gets real y'all
got it which is amazing
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and
share the show with your friends become
a member at timcast.com we're gonna have
a members only uncensored show coming up
which I imagine will be oh so spicy so
again that'll be up uh timcast.com sign
up you can follow the show at timcastirl
you can follow me at timcast Chadwick
you want to shut anything out
uh yeah thanks for having me on um check
out my book if you can my website
chadwickmore.com and you can find all my
writing at The Spectator right now you
got Twitter or anything like that yeah
at Chadwick underscore more easy enough
yep Blair you want to shut anything out
yeah um everyone should go subscribe to
me on YouTube that's the main one um I'm
on Twitter and Instagram at Ms Blair
white there's an e at the end of Blair
iPhone's auto correct it and people
think there's no e and that's really
frustrating so just search me up and
you'll see all my craziness what's your
YouTube Just Blair white youtube.com
Blair white X all one word well thank
you so much for coming my website is
Luke uncensored.com and if you're
looking for deep Dives on very
sophisticated topics like ball tanning
you could get full on 20 30 minute long
videos describing that in in great
context Luke uncensored.com did a video
today on the Maxwell bombshell interview
very interesting stuff Luke uncensor.com
thanks for having me hey guys and I am
serge.com everywhere and I will see you
guys in the comments as always thanks
we will you went from Linda Jr we will
see we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks